[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETER LUBBERS: Nice.
All right.
All right, let's get started.
Everyone in the back, hopefully,
you can hear me.
Come a little closer.
Amazing turn-out, tonight.
Wanted to give a quick, huge
round of applause to Google
for hosting us, for feeding
us, for live-streaming us.
That's incredible.
So a round of applause
for Google.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: All right,
tonight's hashtags are here.
There we go.
All right, SFHTML5,
perfmatters.
And wanted to also give a shout
out to the folks from
the Grant-Eddie Winery
that are in the back.
Maybe a round of applause for
them for all the great wines.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: And for
Rocky, for DJing this
great music for us.
He will be back in the break.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: So I should have
clicked through here a
little bit.
All right.
So first of all, I want to thank
you all for coming and
say a couple of words about the
sponsors that keep these
events free and possible.
Again, the first one,
specifically to Google
Developers Live team doing
a great, great job.
Jamie, Brian are here.
They've been working for
four hours to get
the live stream going.
So I also want to say hello
to all the people that are
watching live.
The last time I checked, it was
close to 100 people live
already watching around
the world.
So thanks to them for
putting it on.
Google Developers Live, by the
way, is sort of our Google
developers' TV channel,
if you will.
If you want to know more about
developer tools, or mobile, or
Chrome apps, just go there.
developers.google.com/live
is the place to go.
All right.
I wanted to let you know about
a great event that is
happening in November.
It's called the Chrome
Dev Summit.
It's really a chance
for you to connect
with the Chrome engineers.
It's going to be in
Mountain View.
Registration is going to open
up in early October.
It's going to be pretty limited
seating, as usual,
like 300 or so, we can fit in.
So registration will sell
out pretty quickly.
But it's a great conference.
We're also going to be
live-streaming that using the
Google Developers
Live platform.
So definitely look
out for that.
There's a link there--
g.co/chromedevsummit.
How many of you are
new to SFHTML5?
OK, some of you.
So we have these monthly
meetings.
We've had them now for over
three years, every month,
usually the last Thursday
of the month.
But we have like one of these
big events every month.
And we also host workshops
and other events.
And our next event will
be all about WebRTC.
Actually, it's going
to be two events.
We're going to have three
talks about WebRTC.
Chris Wilson is coming
to talk about it.
We have a guy from vLine.
We have a guy from PubNub
talking about data channels.
It's going to be
a great event.
And it's going to
be on October 9.
Actually, the registration
opened kind of quietly.
We didn't announce it to
the whole group yet.
So you can still get in.
And you know that may
be hard sometimes.
So definitely sign
up for that.
We have that event.
That's a Wednesday evening.
That's not our usual Thursday.
It is going to be live-streamed
as well.
And then the Saturday following
that, we have a
great event, a WebRTC
Hack Workshop.
So actually come in.
You get to run through
a code lab or build
your own WebRTC solutions.
We have a ton of WebRTC experts
from Google and other
companies on hand to really
step you through.
It's a really great way
to get into that.
OK, I wanted to thank Adobe,
one of our sponsors.
Of course, great tools
for HTML5, and great
stuff they're building.
They're extremely active on the
web platform Docs Front.
And that's a cause that's
really near
and dear to our heart.
We really want to push that
forward, get the right web
documentation for all
of the reference
information of the web.
Also--
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: --a great event
coming to San Francisco and
the Moscone Center.
So it's now, I think, the
fifth version of it.
And it's getting bigger
and bigger and bigger.
It's the week of October 20.
There's a day of training,
two days of full
conference, HTML5 DevCon.
I think most of you
have been there.
If you haven't, it's an
extremely good deal, and two
days of full-on conference,
followed by more training.
So there's some great
sessions.
Anne Burkett is here.
She can tell you more about
it at the break.
But basically check it
out, HTML5 DevCon.
What's the date?
October 22 and 23, and around
that there's days of training.
We have a new sponsor, PubNub.
They make software for real-time
publishing and
subscribing to data right
in your application.
They actually have publish and
subscribe as JavaScript
functions, making it really easy
to create real-time data
feeds and applications
around that.
OK, Bountysource is here.
They're going to be doing a
little lightning talk at the
end of the first break.
So they'll come back, and they
will also be raffling off some
great prizes.
And by the way, HTML5 DevCon
will also be raffling off two
tickets to the conference.
And there will be three Chrome
Dev Summit tickets.
Peter, do you want to say a
little bit about the Kaazing?
One of our founding sponsors--
PETER MOSKOVITS: Sure,
thank you.
My name is Peter Moskovits.
And I'm here representing
Kaazing.
Kaazing has been a sponsor of
SFHTML5 since its inception.
Kaazing has a high-performance,
enterprise
grade, very secure, very
scalable WebSocket server.
We are a start-up down
in Mountain View.
We have about 50 employees
at the moment.
And we are hiring very
aggressively.
So if you're interested in
evangelist roles, you're
interested in engineering,
please come and find me.
Thank you.
PETER LUBBERS: All right.
Ben, one of our new
sponsors Intel.
Ben, do you have a couple of
words to say about Intel?
BEN ODOM: Yeah.
Hey, my name's Ben Odom.
I'd just like to talk a little
bit about our new XDK NEW,
integrated development
environment for HTML5--
totally redesigned, browser
independent, works in Mac,
Linux, Windows, totally free,
has brackets integrated.
We use Cordova 2.9.
It allows you to publish to
pretty much every platform out
there, Windows, Android, pick
your favorite stores.
You can also do web apps.
So there's some cards over there
to tell you where to get
it-- software.intel.com/html5.
Take a look.
Give us some feedback
in the forums.
And we appreciate it.
Thank you.
PETER LUBBERS: Thanks, man.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: All right, so
we have Vitamin T here, a
special sponsor for this
particular event.
Want to say a couple of words?
GLORIANNE: Thank you.
PETER LUBBERS: We have a pretty
long break, as well.
So you can meet up with
the sponsors then.
GLORIANNE: Hi.
I'm Glorianne.
And this is Ariel.
We are here from Vitamin T.
So Vitamin T is a creative
staffing agency.
We're a division of Aquent, our
parent company, which is
the global leader in
creative staffing.
So what do we do?
We help people like
you find jobs--
front-end developers, visual
designers, UX designers.
It could be temp to perm,
freelance, full-time,
contract, remote, off-site,
whatever.
You name it, we can help.
So if you're on the market, or
if you have friends who are
looking, please come
and find us.
We're in the back right next
to the registration table.
And also, a little surprise,
we have a giveaway, too.
We're going to be raffling off
this awesome GoPro camera.
So please, stop by.
Drop of your business card.
If you don't have one,
you can just put your
name on one of ours.
And we'll give it away
at the very end.
OK, thanks so much.
PETER LUBBERS: Thank
you, Glorianne.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: All right.
One of our special sponsor
for tonight is Dice.
And I don't know if you've seen
it, the Dice Tech Trek
bus is back in town.
That looks like this.
One of our members won this at
a previous event and had a
blast, basically, be taken all
through San Francisco.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes,
that's right.
PETER LUBBERS: Tell
us more about it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So with
dice.com, come and
see us at our table.
If you register with dice.com,
even if you're not looking for
a job, there's all kinds of
great stuff on there.
You can get a T-shirt You
can get Dice pens.
But we're going to
be raffling off a
couple of things tonight.
One with you guys, and one over
here, back at our table.
But we've got the
coffee maker.
But the best thing is an
all-expense paid tour tomorrow
night, for you and two
of your friends.
And we're going to take
several winners.
And we're going to
go to dinner, and
dessert, and a bar.
And we pay for the
whole thing.
And the bus is amazing.
It was Lenny Kravitz'
tour bus.
Now, it's the Dice bus.
So come check it out
on the way out.
And we'll stay around for
a while afterwards.
So you can register at
the table and go
check out the bus.
PETER LUBBERS: Thank you.
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: All right.
So hopefully, you all have
a raffle ticket.
Because we have some great
prizes tonight.
We have a Chromebook Pixel.
Some of these sponsor prizes.
We have wine from Grant-Eddie.
There's actually two
raffles for that.
There's a regular raffle,
wine prizes.
If you want to increase your
chance for more wine, drop off
you name for their
mailing list.
And you get an additional
chance to win.
All right, so I want to hand it
over for the first speaker.
So I'm really excited
about the four
speakers we have tonight.
Actually, Jake and Paul came
all the way from London.
And we said, wow,
this is great.
You're here in town.
Colt and Paul are
already here.
Let's do a performance talk
with four speakers.
And I'm really excited.
The first speaker
is Colt McAnlis.
He's a past speaker.
He's one of our alumni.
You know him from the Udacity
study group that
we've hosted here.
If you're not familiar with that
study group or if you're
not familiar with the HTML5
game programming Udacity
course, definitely
check that out.
We did this eight-week study
group here, right in the
Google office, actually.
So I want to hand
it over to Colt.
Colt is a developer advocate
at Google.
He focuses primarily
on performance.
And a round of applause
for Colt.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: Need
me to get that?
COLT MCANLIS: Can we switch over
my slides right there?
Hey, real quick, everybody.
You have no idea how hard it
is to plan one of these
events, put it together with
all of us crazy people, as
well as the catering
and the prizes.
Peter Lubbers and Vanessa and
everybody involved with this
meet-up had done
an amazing job.
Can you give them a
round of applause
for free beer, please?
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
PETER LUBBERS: Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: You
do have a mic on.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah,
I got a mic.
How am I doing on
the live feed?
MALE SPEAKER: Do you want the
podium mic or the handheld mic
for the room?
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
PETER LUBBERS: OK, right.
COLT MCANLIS: How's that?
MALE SPEAKER: We'll all
just wave to you.
COLT MCANLIS: Can you
hear me in the back?
AUDIENCE: No.
COLT MCANLIS: No?
How about now?
Up more?
PETER LUBBERS: One second,
we'll fix that.
OK.
COLT MCANLIS: We make
self-driving cars, for serious.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: We can do this.
We can do this.
All right, we good?
In the back, up?
Down?
Middle?
Bald?
Someone said, I'm bald.
That's not cool, dude.
I saw that.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: All
right, we good?
No, maybe, all right.
I'm just going to
keep talking.
How about that?
PETER LUBBERS: Yes, Brian,
do we need to turn it up?
MALE SPEAKER: As high
as you can get it.
COLT MCANLIS: High
as we can get it.
How about we do--
PETER LUBBERS: Well, here.
Maybe we can do--
COLT MCANLIS: Maybe.
Testing, testing, testing.
Put this down.
I don't know.
How about I do the hand mic?
How about I do that?
How's this?
Is this better?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: How come when you
get a mic in your hand and
you're in front of people,
you just feel sexy?
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: You feel like you
want to talk, talk to you.
I feel your pain, right?
If there's anything I could do
to entertain a crowd while
technical problems
are going on.
All right, my turn.
Fantastic.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
I am the team lead for the
performance section of Chrome
Developer Relations.
And tonight, I want to talk
to you about the joys of
static-memory JavaScript.
Now, I'm going to let you know
that I gave a great talk at
the HTML5 DevCon earlier
this year in April.
And I had a little section in
my talk about static-memory
JavaScript.
And bar none, the most questions
I got was about
static-memory JavaScript.
And so I actually went back,
and I actually wrote this
presentation a couple
months ago.
And I was very happy that Peter
allowed us to do it tonight.
But it was really interesting.
Because when we tried to get
this thing together, really it
was a one-off shot, right?
We had to get the guys from
Europe in town, and they only
had availability for a window.
And then we had to figure out
what day of the week we had
availability for Google's
facilities, and catering, and
all this other crazy stuff.
And it was the most random shot
in the dark for us to end
up on September 19.
Now, I'm in a room
full of nerds.
Does anyone know what
September 19 is?
AUDIENCE: Aarrr!
COLT MCANLIS: Yaarrr!
COLT MCANLIS: Now, I'm
a very simple man.
And I had to stand in the mirror
a couple days ago.
And I had to ask myself, how
much of a man I was.
If I could take this opportunity
to give a talk on
the most random shot day to be
able to give a talk in front
of a room full of my fellow
nerds and actually do the
entire thing as a pirate.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Aarrr!
COLT MCANLIS: My wife didn't
believe this was possible.
I showed it to her on Google,
that this was a thing.
And so, I'm going to ask you,
tonight, can we do this?
AUDIENCE: Aarrr!
COLT MCANLIS: Listen, ye
bilge rats, I'm asking
ye, can we do this?
AUDIENCE: Aye.
COLT MCANLIS: One more time.
We've been givin'
ye free booze.
Give it to me again!
AUDIENCE: Aarrr!
COLT MCANLIS: Aarrr!
Now, that's the crew I be
lookin' to have tonight.
Aye.
Now, tonight, we be talkin'
about one thing in common.
We be slay'n the
waste monster.
It's vile tentacles be keepin'
your applications
from going too fast.
I lost me leg and
got a new one.
That's why I hate it.
My name is Captain MainRoach.
And I'm here, not to
save your bodies.
Because the monster
be takin' those.
I'm here for your souls.
Well, the application souls.
I really don't care about you.
But we need a refund on--
I'll get to me point.
If ye be hearin' anything from
Captain MainRoach tonight that
ye want to be tweetin',
make sure you be
usin' the right hashtags.
Because we had those
back in the day.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: And also, be
making sure that ye visit our
website performance
group on Google+.
It be a great place for
a bunch of mootin--
mootineers?
That came out wrong.
All right, this is a little
well rehearsed.
Make sure ye visit it.
Sign up at goo.gl/webperf.
Now, listen here, ye mindless
yellow-bellied dogs.
I'm not here to listen to wallow
and wane about whether
or not ye like the JavaScript
garbage collector.
I'm here to tell you that
it be a vile beast.
It be takin' everything
from ye.
Because as it doesn't it's evil
task, it's going to be
takin' away a little bit
of your frame rate
every single time.
And I'm not here to
debate yer dogma.
I dunna' care what
gods you live to.
Be that of manage memory, or
static memory, or dynamic,
anything else.
I'm here to worship
one god alone.
And that be the one of
application speed.
Can ye say, aarrr?
AUDIENCE: Aarrr!
COLT MCANLIS: One more
time, aarrr!
AUDIENCE: Aarrr!
COLT MCANLIS: Aye, application
speed.
So stow yer noise, tonight.
I won't be debating whether or
not JavaScript's the best
language or the worst
language.
But I'll be telling ye how to
make your applications fast.
Because that's why
you're here.
Aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye.
COLT MCANLIS: Aye.
Yer learnin'.
That's good.
So I'll tell ye the trouble
with memory.
Now, many of ye may not be
versed in the wild seas of
sailing around memory
problems.
But I'll tell ye,
I've been there.
I lost me hair, and me family.
It be a vile place to be.
From the depths of hell,
memory management
come and it take ye.
It take everything
in yer life.
I'm here, but a husk of a man,
trying to make sure ye do not
follow the same path.
Let's tell ye why.
So when yer out sailing with yer
buccaneers, having a good
time writing yer web
applications, sooner or later,
one of ye's goin'
to drop dead.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: In yer web
application, one of them will
be running around, allocating
memory or adjustin' the DOM.
And sooner or later, it'll have
one too many pints of
beer and die.
We're pirates.
It happens.
But, now, I tell ye this.
It's corpse won't go away.
No, your crew have better things
to do than remove it.
Instead, you leave it on the
ground, festering, when the
rats come and pick
at its bones.
And the gnats come and lay
in its eye sockets.
And the gulls come and
feast on its flesh.
And only then, only then when
the monster gets a whiff of
the piles of corpses that you
been leavin' around in yer
application, only then, will it
summon it's bulbous arms to
yer poop deck.
Poop deck joke, that's good?
Poop deck?
More poop deck jokes?
OK.
And when this beast come and
find yer vessel, it dunna'
know who's living
and who is dead.
It's a blind beast filled
with hate and rage.
It'll bring its tentacles
up aboard yer vessel.
And it'll sniff every one of yer
crew to figure out which
one be inactive, and which one
still be on the stack, ready
to be used again at
a future date.
[LAUGHTER]
And when it finds its evil prey
that it be eatin' on,
it'll take it away from ye.
And only then, will yer dinghy
be operating at peak
efficiency, now that all the
corpses have been hauled away
on your behalf, ye
lazy captain.
But I tell ye this.
The beast takes away as
much as it giveth.
Because yer schooner be goin'
fast on its mission.
It be hittin' 60 knots
per second.
Everyone knows, that's the
magical speed of a boat.
And as it be goin' at 60 knots
per second, all of a sudden,
those piles of corpses
will rise high.
And you'll hear it.
You'll hear the vile beast
comin' from afar.
Its hate, and its dread, and
it's demon-filled life coming
aboard yer vessel, and
it'll stop ye.
And it'll take away those knots,
and stop ye to zero.
And all of yer men aboard yer
ship will stand there idly and
wait for it to do its
demon-filled task.
Meanwhile, your users are
standing there, asking why yer
ship is not moving.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: And ye can't be
like, it's the monster.
It's not me.
Because they blame
the captain.
And then you get fired.
And ye have to talk like
a pirate all day.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: And when it's done
with it's deadly task,
it'll let ye on yer way,
only to catch ye,
again, in the future.
This be the cycle that it lives
and breeds off of, your
reluctancy to allow the corpses
to lay around because
you've got better things
to do, like CSS.
Aarrr, I be a venture pirate
from back in the days of C++,
where a man had to manage his
own memory, and his stack
overflows, and threading
problems, and kernel issues.
But that be a simpler
time then.
We didn't really have
user interfaces.
It was mostly command prompt.
Moving on.
what ye be needin' to know, is
that this monster can strike
at any time, any time
it chooses.
It doesn't matter what you
think it should be doin'.
It's going to do what
it wants, be it a
CallbackHandler, or when the
frame is updating, any time
your JavaScript-style dinghy
be floatin' on the water,
it'll rear its ugly head
as it sees fit.
And you should know that the
most important thing about
your vessel is that it
stays constant at
60 knots per second.
It doesn't care what ye want.
It cares for the flesh
it's come to claim.
Aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye.
COLT MCANLIS: I see some
scared in the house.
They're like, where is
he going with this?
Are we talking about
memory or fishing?
I'm really unclear right now?
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Don't worry.
It'll come down.
Now, here is a great
chart, lads.
You yellow-bellied sea betters
may be lookin' at me and
goin', listen to
this angry man!
He be thinkin' garbage
collections a bad thing.
I'm a friend with that beast.
We go drinkin' on
Friday nights.
No!
It is not yer friend.
It's just usin' ye for free
drinks on Friday nights.
I've been there once.
We'll talk about that later.
If ye dunna' get nothin' from
me diatribe this evening, I
want ye to be rememberin'
this one.
This is a map built by the
most evil of satanic of
scientists that follow
this beast around.
And what ye be lookin'
at here is two
distinct groups of lines.
The first group is done by the
responsible captains who send
their crew to the evil task of
managing the dead themselves.
Now, aye, it does take a little
bit more memory for the
captain to ensure that the crew
is doing the right thing,
tossing its shipmates
overboard.
But you can see on the other
side is the one where the
kraken, the evil corpse
monster be doin'
the work for ye.
Now, these lines mean
nothin' right now.
But I'll tell ye what
they do show.
On the bottom line here these
numbers chart out how much
memory the system has
relative to the
application it be runnin'.
Oh, for yer nautical folk, how
big the sea is compared to the
size of your ship, aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye.
COLT MCANLIS: Aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: Aye!
More beer, aye!
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Now, what ye be
seein' here is three distinct
areas that I wish to be pointin'
out this evenin'.
Because you'll find the
treasure soon, heh?
First, is ye see the bad zone.
If yer memory is between two and
four times the size of yer
vessel, ye be screwed.
[MANIACAL LAUGH].
You want to know why?
Because this kraken beast,
this hate-filled, demon,
bile-covered spawn monster
be larger than ye think.
And when the body of water that
yer schooner be floatin'
in be small, it has nowhere to
put its hefty load of lard.
So it must put it upon
yer vessel, all the
way on the poop deck.
Ye asked for more
poop deck jokes.
I'm going to give them to ye.
You have to laugh now.
[WEAK LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, a
pity laugh, right.
Now, when ye end up in this
second region here, yer doin'
a little bit better.
You can see that four to six
times the size of your memory
requirements are ye be about
average compared to what yer
crew be doin' manually.
This is about the sweet spot
on mobile devices today.
These little devices that they
have that track all of yer
movements as yer goin' about
eatin' yer food and
plunderin', an' pillagin', and
all yer pirate ways, right?
This is where ye be sittin'
with yer memory.
But, unfortunately, that's not
where the sweet spot be for
yer vessel.
Nay, yer ship needs to be in a
wide-open ocean between six
and ten times the amount
of memory that yer
application be needin'.
And it's only then when ye start
to see the hate from
this vile corpse monster
actually be mitigated.
Because the water is able to
hold its massive rolls of
flesh-eating, corpse-filling
bile, drinking--
fat.
Unless yer here,
ye be screwed.
So make sure that yer JavaScript
class schooner
knows what the size of the
water it be goin' in.
If ye remember nothing,
remember this
graph tonight, aarrr.
AUDIENCE: Aarrr.
COLT MCANLIS: Now, I will tell
ye, there be one vessel on the
seven seas that seems
to escape the corpse
monster many times.
And in fact, many have said
that it be the fastest
JavaScript vessel in
all the world.
It's known as the
SS Emscripten.
Do ye know the vessel?
AUDIENCE: Aye.
COLT MCANLIS: I said, do
ye know the vessel?
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: Aye.
You want to know why
it's so fast?
Because it's captain
is damned.
Aye.
Everyone really confused
right now.
Is this an open source boat
that we're talking about?
Because that means lots
of people are damned.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Open source
boat, that would be
interesting.
That's a new Kickstarter.
Ha, ha.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Ya-har!
And the reason its captain be
damned is because, ye know
what he does?
He doesn't let his crew die.
Nay, when he sails from port,
the first evil action he be
doin' is he slaughters
the lot of them.
Slits their throats, standin' on
the deck and let the blood
flow across the planks and
into the water, where the
sharks be feastin'
and the gulls be
squawkin' and nestin'.
And ye know what he does?
He brings a single shaman
on board with his deck.
And that shaman doesn't let
these poor men die.
Nay, he keeps them in some
tribal state of not-dead and
not-livin'.
Not dead enough for the corpse
monster to come aboard.
He manages the dead objects
on his ship, yaarrr.
Is anyone gettin' that yet?
AUDIENCE: Aarrr.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
And what he'll do is he'll
summon a corpse as he needs it
and revive it and then send it
back to dead by slittin' its
throat again.
Aye, this be an evil captain.
But what he does well is he
escapes the kraken monster
once again.
It can never seem to catch this
SS Emscripten, because it
can never find it, because the
corpses never rot and ripen.
You see, this evil bile-flowing,
covered with
boils and rank and fester,
and alimony taking--
umm, uh.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: OK, so I feel I
should tell ye something.
It is true, the monster and
I were once in love.
Ye see, I was a young buccaneer
and hadn't seen much
of the world.
But, ye know, we grow, and we
change, and the monster and I
parted ways.
But we're not here to talk
about me tonight.
But he does take half of me
doubloons every month.
My job tonight, to be keepin'
ye away from the path I be
takin' and teachin' ye how to
use the techniques of SS
Emscripten to keep your
dinghy moving fast.
So we'll start with your own
concept of a corpse pool.
So when ye be gettin' yer mates
on your vessel, make
sure to slaughter them thusly.
Usually across the
neck works fine.
Ye get any fancier than that,
it's just showing off.
I mean, really, come on.
We be pirates.
We simple folk.
Now, when ye need a task done
or ye need a crewman to
achieve a goal for ye, the
best thing to be doin' is
revivin' him.
Use your dark magic.
And what you'll need to be doin'
is ye need to remember
that this corpse, it
has the memories.
It remembers who
it used to be.
So when you grab it off it's
corpse pool, ye need to give
it new clothes and set its
properties so it cannot
remember who it used
to be, and instead,
assumes the goal ye want.
And when ye have a
demon-summoned, dead-filled,
evil corpse to do yer bidding,
you must usually make sure
that it follows that path.
And it does the most evil,
heinous thing that you can
task it to, generally making
the world a worst place for
common folk.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Take a second
to let that sink
in, a zombie on SEPDAT.
Yeah, that would get very
awkward very fast, yaarrr.
And when yer done with it, much
like the SS Emscripten,
ye slit its throat, and put it
back in the pool, and let it
float away.
Again, this will keep the kraken
monster from actually
coming to board yer deck and
takin' away yer speed.
And this is some hieroglyphs
from an ancient time.
But I'll walk through
them anyway.
Because I happen to speak it.
So you can see that to use such
a thing as a corpse pool,
the first thing you need to do
is actually grab a corpse and
revive it, and then set it's
properties accordingly, like
where it will spawn in
the universe, aarrr.
Do a jig.
Walk the plank.
And then when yer done, slit its
throat, throw it back on
the pool, and then make sure
that any clothes ye may have
assigned to it be
cast overboard
to Davy Jones' locker.
He happens to sell things
out of the locker.
That's why it's a locker.
It's actually a second-hand
pirate store, see, aarrr.
That's where we get most
of our clothes, aarrr.
What'll happen is when you use
this sort of pattern of corpse
pools or object pools, what
ye'll be seein' is that your
memory will slowly
grow over time.
It'll be ridin' a wave
that will never end.
And yer ship may never
come back to shore.
It'll just slowly
be increasing.
Now, what ye'll notice, though,
is that ye be spendin'
a lot of time in here, moving
between all these ranks.
And it's worth notin' that under
the hood, JavaScript may
be doin' something that ye not
be planning as captain.
And as captain of your vessel,
you're in charge
of its fate, aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye.
COLT MCANLIS: It's not in
charge of your fate.
It's a boat.
You're the captain, aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye.
COLT MCANLIS: So don't let
it do what you don't
want it to do, aarrr.
AUDIENCE: Aarrr.
COLT MCANLIS: Do ye know under
the hood what happens when you
have a pool of corpses and
ye add another one to it?
Well, if ye've actually maxed
out the number of corpses and
ye add a new one, you know
what yer boat be
doin' behind yer back?
It be creatin' a new pool of
corpses, double the size.
That takes a lot of
extra memory.
I don't know how to say
that in pirate better.
That was a little failure.
That's OK.
We're doing this on
the fly, aarrr.
Now, let's say ye consider
movin' forward again.
And once again, ye get to the
point where instead of 200
corpses, ye added yet another.
And then ye have move again
to 200, to 400 corpses
ye be moving to.
Now, what is interesting about
this is that every time ye add
a corpse to the pile, yer ship
have to go back to bay and
make more room.
Ye need to make changes to yer
hull to accommodate all the
corpses ye be havin'
layin' around.
But once yer hull has
been destroyed, you
have to rebuild it.
So you have to deallocate the
previous array in order to
make room for the new one.
This creates more waste for the
corpse monster to come and
fester, and bleed, and
take away from ye.
It'll be takin' yer
time, lads.
It's not a good thing, aarrr.
AUDIENCE: Aarrr.
COLT MCANLIS: Aarrr, ye
gettin' bored now.
Aarrr!
AUDIENCE: Aarrr!
COLT MCANLIS: Don't worry,
there'll be more booze soon.
Really, what ye need to be
thinkin' ahead as the captain
of yer ship, how many dead
corpses will I need to get
this job done?
Yaarrr, tell that
to yer manager.
That be CEO-level thinking
there, yaarrr.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Yes, yaarrr,
ye see, we can ship a
self-driving car.
But how many corpses can
we fit it in, yaarrr?
I guess that's a question ye
ask in Las Vegas, yaarrr.
Some people got that.
So what ye need to be
thinkin' of is how
many corpses ye need.
And instead of actually going
back to harbor many times, and
rebuildin' yer ship, and getting
more corpses, ye need
to think ahead and hire
the corpses and
kill 'em ahead a time.
And the question that you have,
as simple pirate folk
who are very bad at math, is how
do ye determine the number
of people ye'll need
for this evil task
ye be settin' forward.
And mostly how many knives will
ye need because they kind
of dull over time.
Now, the proper way to be doin'
this is an iterative
testing loop.
Again, that really didn't
translate to pirate.
Just follow with me.
It'll make sense in a minute.
So as yer ship be goin' out, ye
need to be running tests.
Ye need to run through what ye
think the average duration of
your journey be.
And ye need to be figurin' out
how many corpses ye be needin'
over that time.
And every time, you adjust,
and change,
and rebuild yer ship.
And as ye be doin' all this,
ye be rememberin'--
or loggin' out-- what your
maximum number of corpses be,
or yer average number
of corpses, or how
many of them are bald.
Then, ye be tellin' me because
then I'll be upset with ye.
We're mostly discriminated
against, us bald pirates.
We don't have the facial hair.
And so, we can't go to all
the parties, yaarrr.
Once ye average been done
through this process and ye
remember how many corpses ye
may need for your final
journey, only then
can you embark.
And when ye do yer final
journey, ye'll know ahead of
time how many objects to
reference and keep and how
many corpses to slay.
And what we'll end up seein'
is that yer memory profile
will look a little bit more
stair-like, yaarrr.
AUDIENCE: Yaarrr.
COLT MCANLIS: Yaarrr.
And the number of corpses ye
need will statically decrease.
And ye need not go back to
the harbor so many times.
That means ye stay on the water
longer, and ye stay
faster more often, yaarrr.
AUDIENCE: Yaarrr.
COLT MCANLIS: The wind
in yer sails be the
best one about, aye.
AUDIENCE: Aye.
COLT MCANLIS: Now, sooner or
later yer goin' to need to
slit yet another throat, even
though you've pre-allocated
yer corpses.
And when ye do this, ye need to
be thinking back about what
yer ship be doin' without
your knowledge.
Ah ha, ha.
Will ye let it go ahead and
double the arrays every time?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Aarrr.
AUDIENCE:No.
AUDIENCE: Yaarrr?
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: That was the
most awesome response.
Yaarrr?
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Naarrr?
COLT MCANLIS: Nay?
AUDIENCE: Nay.
COLT MCANLIS: The best was I saw
one guy over here look at
his buddy to go, yar--
nay-- nar-- no?
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: What if
we just say, no.
You think he'll point us out?
Quit talkin'.
He's lookin' at us.
The answer is, nay.
Ye not be lettin' the ship
do what it wants.
You're the captain.
You make the rules, yaaarrr?
AUDIENCE: Yaarrr!
COLT MCANLIS: And instead of
allowin' it to double in size
every time, as yer application
needs it and yer DOM changes
and yer objects move, ye be
using what we call a linear
growth array, where instead of
actually usin' the standard
array object, ye be usin'
a linked list
of type static arrays.
So as ye add a single object,
rather than doubling the size
of array, ye only increase
it by certain amounts.
Ye can be 100 corpses, or 1,000
corpses, or a platoon of
corpses if ye choose.
Either way, they're the King's
men, and they're free, ha, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ha.
Sorry, for the British
in the audience.
Yes.
Now, the linear growth array,
actually, be good, because ye
be amortizing the cost
of the corpses
over many, many corpses.
So every time ye allocate a
new array, you're actually
amortizing the death of all
those because ye do it once,
ha, ha, ha.
It's tricky pirate
math, ha, ha.
Look, that be easy to do
in this structure.
Ye can simply index into it with
a little bit of magic and
fluff and dust.
Ye be findin' what ye need.
However, deletion damn
need be impossible.
I do not recommend that.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Don't do that
during a job interview.
It will reflect on you badly.
I'm not saying I've done that.
But do not try that.
The point here be that this is
an app-suited container for
the growth of static corpses
on yer vessel.
It allows ye to grow.
It allows ye to preallocate.
It allows ye to stay fluid when
times change, yaarrr.
And that be the pirate
way, he, he.
Now, for all of ye in the
audience, ye may be saying to
yerself, I have no freakin'
clue what my
memory be doin', yaarrr?
AUDIENCE: Yaarrr.
COLT MCANLIS: Welcome
aboard, mateys.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: That was the
most hearty yaarrr.
Yes, I have no idea what
yer talkin' about.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: I am so
lost right now.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Thanks for
playin' along, lads.
For those of ye lookin' to
understand what's going on
under the hood of your deck,
ye need to be lookin' at a
couple tools To start
off, stick with
Chrome Developer Tools.
It actually be givin' ye a
pretty good understanding of
how many corpses and objects be
used along the duration of
yer trip over time.
And with new tooling on the
bottom, it'll actually tell ye
what heap these corpses be
coming from, be they the audio
heap from the southern regions
of France, or they be the
rendering heap from Jamaica.
[PIRATE LAUGH].
They be a spicy lot,
lads [LAUGHS].
Anyhow, stop here.
Make sure ye run yer application
through the tools.
Figure out where yer memory is
going and adjust accordingly.
Ye be the captain, aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: Another great
tool that's just come out.
However, this shitty
picture was all I
could find on the internet.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Because for some
reason, they don't have anyone
who could put up a more
high resolution
photo of the damn tool.
There's a good tool called
Adobe GCview.
And no, I couldn't
get it workin'.
So I couldn't take the picture
myself, yaarrr.
This is a fantastic external
tool that will allow ye to do
memory profile analysis
for multiple
different browsers, yaarrr.
So for those of ye out here who
may be sayin', oh, Captain
MainRoach, yer kind of off
the plank with Chrome
only, check this out.
But seriously, put up
a better picture.
That's kind of embarrassing.
I'm a pirate and I'm callin'
ye out, yaarrr.
So lads and lasses, my crew
tonight, thank ye for
listenin' to me.
Let me give ye some tips
on how to avoid this
evil-buildin' mulch monster.
First off, know that this
monster be eatin' away at the
speed of yer ship.
And that not be good.
If you don't see that garbage
collection be hurtin' yer
frame rate, yer not tryin'
hard enough.
Build a better application.
Yaarrr, I'm callin'
ye out, yaarrr.
AUDIENCE: Yaarrr.
COLT MCANLIS: Yaarrr.
T-shirt for that man.
The of ye to the planks.
High corpse churn summons
the monster.
If ye be movin' lots of objects
around and not doin'
yer duty, then the corpse
monster will find ye.
It'll slow down yer vessel.
And then, ye'll be cursin'
all day long.
And I will be sittin' back
laughin' [MANIACAL LAUGHTER].
Kill yer crew before ye sail.
Sail them as zombies.
I dare every one of ye in here
to tweet that right now.
Kill yer crew before ye
sail #perfmatters.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: The bald pirate
told me to say it.
I'm not crazy.
Know yer corpse count
by testin' yer
voyage ahead of time.
Be the captain of yer vessel.
Don't let it control you.
You're in charge, yaarrr.
AUDIENCE: Yaarrr.
COLT MCANLIS: That one hurt.
Hold on.
Oh--
I needed to stretch my yaarrr.
When ye need more corpses, make
sure ye linearly grow.
Don't allow the ship to do it.
Ye do it yerself.
In honest, I miss the
corpse monster.
We did separate.
And there were little
'uns involved.
But ye know, we'll
be back soon.
With the new primitives in C++
11, there may be a chance to
get a better high-performance
allocation system, where I may
not have to manage
my memory myself.
That's a separate discussion.
Anyhow, yaarrr, thank ye all for
listenin' to me tonight.
And I'd like to remind
ye that we won't be
takin' questions, now.
But we will be doin' it at the
end of the night in a fireside
chat manner, yaarrr.
Thank ye be for listenin'
tonight.
AUDIENCE: Yaarrr.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: Thank
you, Colt.
All right, Colt, we have a
special gift for you, yaarrr.
COLT MCANLIS: Thank you
very much, yaarrr.
AUDIENCE: Yaarrr.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
COLT MCANLIS: Another round of
applause for the great SFHTML5
team, yaarrr.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: All right, so
for the next talk, we have
Paul Lewis.
He came all the way
from the UK.
And he's a developer advocate
on the Chrome Developer
Relations team specializing
also in performance.
He knows a lot of WebGL, and
it's been just great working
with Paul for the last-- what?
About a year now.
So Paul, are you mic'd
up already?
OK, great.
We have your laptop here.
We'll just switch over.
Oh, the same?
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah, OK.
We're switching over
to laptop.
Like I said, we'll have
one more talk.
Then we have a pretty good break
for about 25 minutes.
We'll have more time to hit
the different sponsor
booths and so on.
There's wine.
And there will be
dessert as well.
So let's just switch
this out right now.
And then, we'll have plenty
of time for a break.
Again, a couple of great raffle
prizes, conference
tickets, and a whole stack
of wine and so on.
So hang on to those
raffle tickets.
We'll have two more talks
after the break.
And then we'll have a Q&A
panel So we don't take
questions right now.
We'll just wait for
that at the end.
And we'll just pass the
mic around the room.
OK.
All right, so, one moment.
MALE SPEAKER: We're
a good team.
PETER LUBBERS: [LAUGHS].
MALE SPEAKER: All right,
thank you.
Do you need to put it behind
this [INAUDIBLE]?
PETER LUBBERS: Hmm?
MALE SPEAKER: Do you need
to put it behind this?
PETER LUBBERS: Maybe.
So it doesn't fall.
OK.
Does he need this?
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PAUL LEWIS: All right,
I got it.
I'm good.
You all good?
You can hear me?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah?
All happy, huh?
[IN PIRATE VOICE]
Now ye may be noticin'--
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: --that today--
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE].
PAUL LEWIS: But I think not.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, but what
I thought I would do is I
thought I'd take a step back for
us now, and I thought I'd
visualize the speakers
for you by help of a
trustee Venn diagram.
Now, on the left, we
have bald people.
On the right, we have Pauls.
Colt, firmly in the bald camp.
Professor Irish, firmly
in the Paul.
Me, making up the middle, the
intersection, if you will.
But unfortunately,
we have Jake--
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: --who's thinning
up top and
trying to get into bald.
I wish him well.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: Now, what I wanted
to do is set the scene.
And I feel like resetting
the scene.
Talking about rendering
performance, there's a lot of
people who kind of go,
eh, I'm not so sure.
What's he mean by rendering?
This performance chat-- and
often, what we've done, I
think, is we've gone, OK.
How long does this thing
takes to load?
How many requests am I making?
Have I got GZip switched on?
What about eEtags?
They're dead.
Ew, I don't know what to do.
And I understand why
we've done it.
But the thing is, it's only
part of the picture.
OK, it's only part of the
problem, because as Colt
discussed with the memory
thing, you know, that's
something that doesn't fit into
page load time, right?
And that's a part
of performance.
So it's a little bit
of a question.
And so, what I thought I'd do
is just a quick, highly
technical chart for myself.
of two apps.
App one is fast to load
and slow to render.
And App two is slow to load
and fast to render.
And which is worse?
Which is better?
Well, the answer, of course, is
both of those are going to
hack off your users.
They are not going to
be happy with you.
So it matters.
So what I thought I would then
do is take us through the
pipeline a little
bit like this.
The idea here is from a page
load perspective-- because
that means we will hit every
part of the pipeline--
I want to get through from how
the browser does a request and
gets pixels onto the screen.
That's actually the job
of the browser.
It's there to get content
on your users' screens.
So it's good to understand it.
And then when your users are
scrolling, and dragging stuff
about, and just generally using
your site or your app,
then we'll hit parts of
this pipeline again.
So it's good to understand it.
And this is part one of two.
Because I would normally talk
about the DevTools-y part of
this, where you can figure
out how your
project is actually working.
But Paul Irish is going
to actually do
that part later on.
So think of this as
a scene setter, a
part one, if you will.
Now, we start off our journey
with the humble GET
request, like so.
Our server is going to respond
for us with some HTML, all
pretty awesome.
And the first thing that the
browser is going to do-- and
it does clever stuff with
doing streamed, and look
aheads, and all this kind
of stuff-- but it
starts to parse that.
And when you look in DevTools,
you'll see things like Parse
HTML, which is this process,
really, of taking our tag soup
and turning it into this,
which is the DOM.
And that's the DOM
for that HTML.
So we'll just make our lives a
little bit easier and just
call it the DOM.
And then what we do is we take
the CSS, and we're just going
to add that plus in there.
We take the CSS, and some of
that CSS will come part of the
browser as the default
style sheets.
With the browser, there's the
stuff you put in line.
There's the stuff that's
in your style sheets.
And we start to actually figure
out from the DOM what
CSS applies to what.
And historically, people have
spent quite a lot of time
trying to optimize
CSS selectors,
you know, how quickly.
And it's actually a bit of a
waste of your time because the
browser is very, very,
very fast at
doing selector matching.
So just bear that one in mind.
Anyway, this will show up in
DevTools as Recalculate Style.
So what happens-- and I'm about
to do a sound effect, I
can feel it coming on--
we put these together like--
[FART NOISE]
PAUL LEWIS: --that.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: And we get
the Render Tree.
Paul Irish is happy
with that noise.
He's happy with that.
Now, the Render Tree looks
distinctly like the DOM,
except that things are missing,
like the head, for
example, or a script.
They're not there because
we're not
going to render them.
So they don't appear
in that tree.
But let's say, for example, I
decide that in my style sheets
I'm going to put section
p-- boop.
I'm going to say,
Display None.
That will disappear from the
Render Tree because it's set
to Display None.
It's not something we're
going to draw.
It's not something
we care about.
Equally, I could have a pseudo
element, and that would add
something into the
Render Tree.
So the Render Tree, as I said.
It looks like the DOM,
but it's not the DOM.
It's the styles applied
to the DOM.
So that's that.
Now, the next job-- and it's
going to look like a really
simple job.
We've got all this CSS that
we want to apply.
And it's basically like widths,
and heights, and
display blog, position
absolute, all
this kind of stuff.
And what the browser has to do
is take that and go, whoof,
where does everything
live on screen?
Why are there boxes here?
And as you probably know, this
can actually get extremely
expensive because everything
tends to be contingent on
everything else.
So if I were to change the
height of Body, everything
that's inside Body needs
to be recalculated.
And this will show itself up
in DevTools as Layout.
And, yeah, that's where all
those boxes are coming from.
Good.
So the next job that we
have is to actually
fill in some pixels.
We know where those boxes are.
But they now need filling
in with pixels.
So we need a rasterizer.
Now, just a bit of terminology
in case you don't spend your
time looking at this stuff.
Vectors are basically shapes
that we have the mathematical
formulae for, or we have the
positions of the corners, for
example, in the case
of a triangle.
But we're interested
in actually pixels.
So what we actually have to do
is we have to figure out from
our triangle which pixels we
need to fill in and what color
they need to be.
And this is the process of
converting vector to raster.
OK?
All pretty simple.
Now, if you and I were to have a
fun afternoon and we were to
create a rasterizer, we'd
probably include
methods like this.
And I know that we would,
because these are the ones
from Chrome's rasterizer,
which is called Skia.
And so you can imagine there
drawPoints, drawOvals,
drawRectangles, drawBitmaps,
draw some text.
And if you've worked with the
HTML5 canvas, a lot of this
stuff will actually look
quite similar.
It's the rasterizer,
basically.
So now what we can do, I
actually run that HTML through
Skia and said, what
did you do?
And it told me.
So if thought I'd show
you what it does.
Ta-daaa!
But you probably didn't
see what was going on.
So why don't we have ourselves
an instant replay.
Now, you'll see that as we get
through each of these calls,
we're starting to build up
the picture of what's
actually going on.
Draw around the rectangle, which
isn't that clear, but
that's the drop shadow.
Draw the path.
Here we go.
Draw the bitmap, which
is my face.
Do a bit of tidy up, and
we'll call it a day.
DevTools is going to show
you that as Paint.
That's how it goes about letting
you know that it did
some of that work.
Now, some of this bears a little
bit more scrutiny, I
think, specifically,
drawBitmap.
Now, I was a good developer.
I sent through my tiny JPEG.
I compressed it.
I'm good on the page load time.
I'm happy.
Well done, me.
But you'll notice that it's
called drawBitmap and not
drawJPEG, or drawPING,
or drawGIF--
''jif," "gif"--
Hands up for "gif." Ooh,
it's going to be close.
Hands up for "jif."
You're wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL LEWIS: There not
"jraphics," are they?
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: All right?
Anyway, so now, we
have our JPEG.
And we basically go through, and
we're going to decode out
an image into a bitmap--
red, green, blue, and
possibly alpha.
But the thing is, we're also
maybe doing a bit of
responsive web design.
So we also have to do
some resizes as well
on the other side.
So these are extremely
expensive.
They show up in DevTools.
You can spin down
Paint records.
And you'll see image decodes
and image resizes.
And they will kill your frames
per second, if you have them,
particularly, resizes,
actually.
OK, so we spent some time
we drew a bitmap.
The next thing we want
to look at is--
we're quite fancy-- we're going
to do a bit of animation.
What we're going to actually end
up doing is we're going to
move that picture of
me up to there.
Now, when this happens, we
basically took this rectangle
around everything and said, this
is now damaged and dirty.
This area needs fixing.
This needs repainting.
So we actually have to step
through one-by-one and re-run
all those commands with the
drop shadow, and the white
box, and the bitmap.
And it doesn't take much
imagination to figure out that
if we have a lot of things that
need painting, or we move
something a really, really
long way, that could be a
hugely expensive thing
that we just did.
So what we do to work around
that is we do these things
called layers.
Instead of having one surface
that we rendered into, that we
rasterize into, we
have several.
So this is my website.
And actually, the masthead
thing is a canvas.
So why don't we boost that
out a little bit.
Now, what happens is we
can basically do this.
So that when we want to change
something in the masthead, we
don't have to worry about
repainting the thing behind.
We keep it separate.
This is extremely useful.
What's also interesting about
this-- or at least to me,
because I'm a nerd--
is the Next and Previous buttons
are actually DOM
elements on their own, right?
But they're sitting on top of
something that was just
boosted out to its own layer.
So what Chrome ends up doing
is it ends up creating more
layers, just for those.
So you actually end up with
four of the suckers.
And these all get sent across
the GPU, which we'll talk
about in a second.
And then composited layers
is what you're
going to see in DevTools.
It's taking all these layers
and all this stuff.
And it's basically going,
"schwip," putting them all
together again, figuring out
what layers it needs, where
they need to live, all
that kind of stuff.
So those are the layers.
They're pretty cool.
And you might be asking
yourself--
I hope you are--
how do I get a layer?
That's exciting to me.
You'll notice it's subject
to change because it's an
implementation detail.
But all the same, let's
have a look at them.
3D or perspective transform,
anybody use the
node transform hack?
Anybody translate z happy?
Yeah?
Work for you?
Good.
OK, that's the classic one.
Video elements, canvas elements,
composited plugins,
like Flash or Silverlight,
an animation on opacity,
interesting.
Transform filters, like Blur
and all those ones.
And then the last one,
which are my Next
and Previous buttons.
Those are rendered on top
of another layer.
So those are the ones.
You could imagine that we
might add some more.
We might.
So the last little part--
and this is the
website from tonight--
is to actually take those
rastered images and send them
across the GPU.
Now, the thing to bear in mind,
all that rasterization
that we did was done actually
on the CPU.
And when we do rasterization--
this is a small detail.
I just wanted to include it
for completeness' sake.
We actually rasterize
into tiles.
It doesn't make any difference
to us as developers, but I
just like to include
it, I don't know.
So there we go.
That doesn't matter
for what we do.
But we have the CPU.
All this work so far has
happened on the CPU.
So when people are talking about
hardware accelerated
this and that, so far,
everything we've
done was on the CPU.
The last thing that we actually
end up doing at this
point is sending those tiles
across to the GPU.
Happy days.
And that was a nice
simple animation.
But the bandwidth between CPU
and GPU might be quite
constrained, especially
on a mobile device.
It's very easy to saturate
that link.
And if you're doing a lot of
repainting, you're just
sending a lot of stuff across
to the GPU, you
might really struggle.
So it's a finely
balanced thing.
Anyway, that's going to show
up as composite layers.
And finally--
whoosh, there we go-- we end up
with something on screen.
So now we know how you get from
the humble GET request
all the way through to some
pixels on screen.
So with that said, I am now
interested in the bit where we
control the workload.
I really want to ask
[PIRATE VOICE]
are ye the captain
of yer ship?
Aarrr!
But I'm not going to.
But we are.
And so, seeing as we're in
control, let's talk about some
millisecond stuff
for a second.
Let's frame what we're
interested in.
When a user interacts with your
site or your application,
we have 100 milliseconds in
which to respond for that user
to feel like it was an
instant response.
If we take more than 100
milliseconds to respond to the
user's interaction,
we have failed.
They will notice.
The second thing that we care
about is 16 milliseconds.
If we're doing anything like
scrolling, or dragging, or
anything that's regularly
animating and updating the
screen, we have 16 milliseconds
in which to get
all the work done.
So this is just to frame our
argument here-- response time,
100 milliseconds; frame
time, 16 milliseconds.
OK?
Bear that in mind.
Now, all I'm going to do at
this point, as I said,
normally, I'd show you
some DevTools.
But I'm going to just talk about
some stuff you want to
look at, some stuff you
need to be careful of.
And then Paul will actually run
you through DevTools and
the tools that are
available to you.
Small style changes can have
big layout knock-ons.
If you're, say, changing Body,
as I explained before, we have
to re-layout everything.
Huge deal if you're trying
to do that in an
animation, for example.
You decide you're going to
change some high-level
element, like one or two
levels into the DOM,
everything's probably going
to get recalculated.
That will kill you in terms
of your frame rate.
This is something of a common
misconception, that layout is
somehow always triggered
by JavaScript.
It's not.
You can have a transition that's
in response to a hover.
It's not done by JavaScript.
But it's layouts all the same.
And layout isn't painting.
Now that you've been through
that pipeline with me, again,
there's often a misunderstanding
the layout
is, somehow, painting.
But actually, if you do change
the position of something, we
might need to repaint.
And we'll have a look
at something that's
doing that in a second.
There's a thing that looks
a little bit like this.
And the code, it doesn't really
matter too much what
the code is doing.
But I'll tell you
what it's doing
anyway, just for a laugh.
We're going through
some paragraphs.
And we've got some other element
that we want to match
the widths of all our
paragraphs to.
So the first thing we do is we
ask for the width of this
thing called "green block." Now,
we asked for its offset
width, which causes Chrome--
and, in fact, any web kit
or blink-based browser--
to go off and do a
layout operation.
Go, what's the width of the
green block, please?
And then, we set the first
paragraph's width.
And then we go through that loop
over, and over, and over,
and over, and over again.
And that is, effectively, read,
write, read, write,
read, write, read, write,
read, write.
And that's not a good thing.
Because every single write
invalidates the previous read.
This is called layout
thrashing.
You do not want this in
your applications.
What you wanted to do--
there we go--
was to ask for the width once.
Read, write, write, write,
write, write.
Happy days.
Paint--
show you this demo, right.
There's this brilliant tool
called "show paint
rectangles." If you're ever
wondering whether something's
painting in Chrome,
that is your tool.
And what's going to
happen is, see, I
select some text, right?
And you get this red
box around it.
And that's, basically, Chrome
saying, I had to do some
repainting here, Paul.
Thanks, Chrome.
I expected you to do
it, and you did.
You're so reliable.
Anyway, so what I've got is I've
got these buttons, and
your scroll bar--
that's getting repainted-- now,
I've got this button up
here that says Animate.
It is a highly realistic
animation.
Look at this, woo!
Now, the interesting thing here
is that this one big area
needed repainting because we're
moving everything inside.
But we can also figure out
that they've all been
flattened down to one surface,
one layer that we're actually
painting into, right?
So this is the thing that's
getting invalidated.
It needs repainting.
That might be slow.
So we're quite smart.
What we want to do is we're
going to use the translate z
hack to isolate all
those boxes.
And all we're doing is moving
them around, and the GPU is
really good at just moving
stuff around.
It's fantastic at it.
So we're going to do that.
There we go.
Change them to black, just
so it's a bit easier.
And then, you see, we're
not painting anymore.
Because we painted them once,
all these layers.
And then we just asked the
GPU to move them around.
This is an awesome way of using
the translate z hack.
I've come full circle.
I used to hate it.
Now I love it, just
for this reason.
The danger that we
then have is--
I'm just hovering over
it in this--
animate the radii.
Now, these boxes have a slightly
rounded corner.
What I've got is I've got an
animation queued up that's
going to change the border
radius of each of those boxes.
Ready?
Aa-aa-aa-aah!
Daah!
Look how much it crawls!
So it's not always a good thing
to isolate everything
and put a translate
z hack on it.
Because you can end up creating
a lot of extra work
if you end up having to paint
each one of these things.
These all need rerasterizing.
And then they all need copying
over to the GPU.
Eeew!
Should be what you feel.
So this tool is amazing.
When you want to figure out, is
something getting repainted?
What's getting repainted?
Switch on that tool, have
a look at what goes red.
If you see a big red flash
across your whole screen,
you've probably got a problem.
OK?
So that's a good way
to find that out.
So painting, avoid it.
You can't avoid it on the first
time you page load.
But you want to try
after that.
You can promote elements
to isolate them.
If you have one element that
is moving around and maybe
does need repainting, promoting
it is, actually,
often a really good way to just
make sure that nothing
else has to be repainted
unnecessarily.
But bear in mind that it can
also spoil other layers like I
showed you with the Next
and Previous buttons.
You just want to be
careful with it.
Layers themselves do actually
have a knock-on effect for
memory, the management, and the
transfer, as I mentioned.
So just be careful with that.
Often people say, well, how
many layers can I have?
And there isn't a good
answer to that.
Because it depends on the device
that you're talking
about and whatever else you're
actually trying to do.
So just profile it and see if
you can see how your frames
per second's doing and respond
to that, really.
Paint storms, we were debating
this term earlier, what it
really means.
What it really comes down to
is you wouldn't want to be
caught in an actual storm.
You don't want to be caught
in a paint storm, either.
It's generally you're
doing paint that you
shouldn't be doing.
You're either painting too much,
or you're painting too
often, all those
kind of things.
It's just a nice name for saying
it's not what you want
to be doing.
You're doing too much paint.
So don't do that.
Interestingly, because the GPU
is exceptionally good at these
things particularly, they often
don't cause paints.
If you something, isolate an
element and then monkey around
with it, so opacity and
transforms, we won't be
repainting.
Like those boxes, they
didn't repaint.
Happy days.
We all smiled a happy smile.
Image decodes and resizes,
those are done on demand.
So when we're rasterizing, we
hit one of those drawBitmap
calls, we actually queue up
the decodes and resizes.
So it can make for very
sporadic frame
rates, let's call it.
Because we do it on demand.
So when something comes into
view that we need to
rasterize, we go and
get the image.
We decode it, which
could kill us.
And for all intents
and purposes,
that's not a good thing.
So bear in mind that handling
images is expensive.
You can't really avoid
images on the web.
But just bear in mind that
handling them is expensive.
So you want to see if
you can mitigate it.
And one of the best ways to
do that is actually avoid
resizing them when you can.
And I say that, uh,
frustratedly.
Because responsive web
design is A, popular
and B, quite cool.
But it does put a really heavy
tax on the browser.
So if you're going to do it,
just know that there's a tax.
And be happy to pay the tax.
There you go.
Now, requesting an animation
frame, if you've not come
across it, when you are changing
things on-screen,
please avoid these.
They are not timed to the
browser's refresh cycle.
So they will just run whenever
suits, and that could be at
the worst possible time
for the browser.
What you want to do is
use friendly green
requestAnimationFrame.
It's so helpful.
Anybody use jQuery?
Yeah?
Anybody us jQuery animate?
OK.
It currently uses
set interval.
I would love that to change.
In fact, I actually double
checked that
from the jQuery source.
It does use set interval.
There are patches that you can
apply that then switch it back
to requestAnimationframe, simple
enough thing to do.
And it might be worth it for
your project if you are using
jQuery animate, as
it stands today.
Scrolling performs is a big,
big deal, actually.
Because most the time, people
scroll on the web.
Apparently, it happens
quite a lot.
Scrolling then, it does
cause paints.
Because as content becomes
visible, we have to rasterize.
We have to paint that stuff.
So we want to make sure
that when we do it,
we keep things light.
The easiest thing to do
with scrolling is
to avoid doing anything.
There's a really good one,
actually, that you might want
to look at.
It doesn't take too
much imagination.
If you were scrolling through
and you trigger a hover on an
element, as you're scrolling,
then we have to repaint the
thing that you hovered.
Then you keep scrolling,
and you hover out.
And we have to repaint the thing
that you now hovered
out, just because you were
scrolling past it.
Now, if your hover effects are
really expensive, that's going
to be awful.
What you want to do is you want
to, basically, switch off
anything changing.
So you basically add a class
or something that basically
switches off hover effects
while your scrolling.
You know, waste a little
bit of time.
Then switch them
back on again.
Happy days.
There's a "HTML5 Rocks"
article about
that, that I wrote.
Pretty good.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: I, mean
the idea is good.
It wasn't my idea.
I just wrote it up.
Anyway, debounce scroll
handlers.
What do you possibly
mean, Paul?
I mean this.
If you aren't a scroll listener
to your window, in
this case, don't do anything
inside that scroll handler.
Please, for the love of all that
is decent, don't do it.
What you do, store the
value if you need to.
Great.
Super.
And then schedule a
requestAnimationFrame to
handle the scroll, the
thing that happened.
Because you could get 5,
10, 20 of these events.
But really, you probably
only want one.
You want the last one, most
likely, to know the current
scroll position because you're
doing a parallax site.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: What?
Whoo!
Just because it's cool, doesn't
mean it's right.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: Just throw
that out there,
if anybody's listening.
OK, last thing I want to do--
because we're running low on
time-- is just do a little bit
of myth-busting.
JavaScript, you'll
notice I haven't
talked about it at all.
You, maybe, thought
I would, right?
Because when we're not talking
about page load time, we're
talking about JavaScript and how
slow it is and horrible.
But it's not, actually.
Work is often triggered
by your JavaScript.
You maybe changed your class
with dot class name, or class
list, or something, whatever.
It's often triggered
by JavaScript.
But the work that's actually
running is often
carried out in C++.
Layout is not done
in JavaScript.
Layout is done in C++.
It's done lower down.
So bear that in mind.
And slow JavaScript--
you know, this idea that,
oh, JavaScript is slow.
And that's why the mobile
web is slow.
No, it's not actually the
reason most of the time.
Because it's not JavaScript
that's actually running.
It's the other stuff that's
inside the browser that's
actually running.
Unless you're making
a game or--
there are classes of
applications that do rely on
JavaScript quite heavily.
I do want to say that I'd like
you to start treating
JavaScript benchmarks with deep,
unyielding cynicism.
Because JavaScript probably
isn't your bottleneck.
Layout probably is
your bottleneck.
Paint is probably
So you know, if you start
seeing, oh, it's really fast--
with JavaScript.
Yay!
And then, the other thing
is, the DOM is slow.
You hear this one quite a lot
for fairly similar reasons to
the last, actually.
Interacting with the
DOM is, actually,
quite fast, as it happens.
The problem is that changes to
the DOM probably incur changes
that are layout or vCalc
style, layout, paint,
composite--
misery.
So be careful.
Now, going forth, aim for
60 frames per second.
It is well and truly
achievable.
You control the browser's
workload.
You are, in fact, the
ship's captain.
--I brought it round.
Performance is a feature.
It's not a unit test.
It's not something, you
get to the end of the
project, am I fast?
No.
Aah, ship anyway.
Nobody will notice.
Wait until they complain.
That's what we'll do.
No, think of it, put
it on the list.
It might be two, three,
four, but make
sure it's on the list.
Ideally, put it number one.
I do.
I love that.
Profile, then fix.
A lot of times you'll
read things that are
like, this is fast.
Do this.
And that's fine.
Sometimes you need to do that.
But you end up writing things
that don't fix the problem
you've got.
You end up writing something
that makes Paint better.
But you've got a
layout problem.
Profile, use DevTools.
Paul will show you how.
Profile your stuff.
Figure out where you're
actually slow.
Then fix that thing.
Sounds simple enough,
because it is.
Profile early.
Profile often.
Smile a happy smile.
Do it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL LEWIS: Time for
a break, isn't it?
Yes.
PETER LUBBERS: Paul, thank
you for speaking.
Here's our San Francisco
HTML5 speaker gifts.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, cool.
PETER LUBBERS: Original
painting--
PAUL LEWIS: Well,
thank you all.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
here you go.
PETER LUBBERS: And a
little bit more.
PAUL LEWIS: Thank
you very much.
PETER LUBBERS: All right,
thanks, everybody.
We have a break.
We need to be back here, seated,
around 8:00, not too
much later to keep
on schedule.
We have dessert out.
We have more wine, beer,
the sponsor tables.
Check it out.
Enjoy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETER LUBBERS: --announcement
by Glorianne.
GLORIANNE: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Testing, testing,
one, two, three.
GLORIANNE: So hi, everyone!
It's Vitamin T again.
And just want to make
an announcement
about the GoPro camera.
So this drawing is separate
from everything else.
You have to give us a business
card in order to be
considered.
We weren't part of the
whole ticket thing.
So it's not going to rely on the
ticket that you received.
It's a business card.
So if you haven't dropped
off a business
card, yet, please do.
[? Ani ?]
and Ariel are walking around
with containers.
So you can drop it in if you
want to be considered.
The odds, right now, look like
they're 100 to one, for a
GoPro camera.
So if you want to get
in the drawing,
please, drop off a card.
All right, thanks.
PETER LUBBERS: Thank you.
All right.
So next up, a quick announcement
about the
Bountysource project.
You want to take it away?
Great, thanks, Warren.
WARREN KONKEL: Hello.
My name is Warren.
I'm one of the founders
of Bountysource.
Bountysource is a crowdfunding
platform
for open-source software.
So you can basically come to
the site and you can place
bounties using Google Wallet,
Paypal, et cetera, on GitHub
issues, Bugzilla issues, Track
issues, and so on.
And so, if you're a developer
looking to earn some extra
beer money or quit your job
and work full-time on open
source, Bountysource
is actually a great
platform to do so.
We work with GitHub, Track,
Bugzilla, all those platforms.
We also have fundraisers,
kind of similar to
how Kickstarter works.
But exclusively for open-source
software.
We've worked with some
large companies
like Adobe and Mozilla.
And we're growing quickly.
So definitely, come
check us out.
We also just launched a new
feature called "teams." So if
you're part of a company and
you want to give your
developers a budget, or you're a
developer and want to have a
budget for yourself to go spend
on bounties, and bug
fixes, and so on, ask your
managers or your co-workers to
come check out Bountysource.
You can basically allocate
$1,000 to a team.
And members can come in.
And when they get a bug,
instead of fixing it
themselves, they can go
create a bounty on it.
Anyways, thank you very much.
If you want to come talk to us,
we're all wearing green
T-shirts that say
Bountysource.
Thank you all for coming
out tonight.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: Thank you.
All right.
OK.
So our talk is now starting.
So Jake Archibald, also here,
all the way from the UK.
We're really happy
to have him here.
He's a developer programs
engineer in the Chrome
Developer Relations team.
And before working at Google,
he worked at Lanyrd and
basically made that whole
site work well
offline, which is amazing.
You may know him from his
douche-bag article.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Ah!
I'm going to shake that.
I need to shake that.
Hey, you're the douche-bag
guy.
Thanks, everyone.
PETER LUBBERS: I can assure you,
he's not a douche-bag.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: [LAUGHS].
PETER LUBBERS: All right.
So thank you, Jake.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hey,
excellent.
OK, people at the back,
how is that?
People at the back,
can you hear me?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Is that good?
Excellent.
I'll try and keep
this volume up.
Wave if I let up, OK.
So I'm going to try
out something
a little bit different.
And it depends on the
Wi-Fi working.
It's been a bit of
a nightmare.
It's probably a stupid idea.
So let's find out.
We're going to do an
interactive quiz.
These slides are going
to be interactive.
So if you don't have a
web-enabled device in front of
you now, get it in
front of you.
A laptop or a phone, it
will work on both.
But make sure you've
got that ready.
It's a quiz.
But it's really just an excuse
to string together some bits
of browser trivia to relate
it to performance stuff.
So what you'll need to do is get
on the Google guest Wi-Fi.
That's the SSID there.
And then if you go to this
lovely URL, which
is my laptop here.
So that's 192.168.156.69,
port 3,000.
And there's a clue.
Yes, it's a node server.
Very nice.
Yeah, if you're watching
the live stream, nah.
That's not going to work.
Sorry.
Just play the game using
your mind or whatever.
Just play with yourself.
No.
Wait.
It doesn't matter.
OK, move on.
Once you go to this URL, you'll
be asked to enter a
username and password.
Just make up any old password.
It's going to be stored in
plain text on my machine.
So don't use your credit card
number unless you wish to make
a donation.
All donations are gratefully
received.
The reason I'm asking for a
password is if you want to
switch devices halfway through,
like you start
running out of batteries or
whatever, you can just enter
the username and password again
on another device and
pick up from where
you left off.
Now, I hacked this thing
together quite quickly.
You could probably break it
by trying to break it.
So please, don't do that.
I've at least made sure our
Little Bobby Tables can play.
So if you're in the room,
you're all right.
Is everyone getting
access to it?
It's kind of working?
Wow, brilliant.
I want to stress that
this quiz is tough.
And I've seen it catch out
people who do this sort of
stuff, this minor details of
browsers for a living, and it
catches them out.
So if you're the kind of person
who flips tables over
when you don't win, then maybe
stay away from tables for a
little bit because this
could get rough.
OK, I'm going to get this huge,
horrible, Helvetica off
the screen.
Oh, of course, what kind of quiz
would be complete without
a grand prize?
[IMITATING GAME SHOW
ANNOUNCER]
The Chromebook Pixel is Google's
latest laptop,
featuring an i5 1.8 gigahertz
processor, 4 gigabytes of RAM,
and the touchscreen with a
higher DPI than a MacBook Pro.
Couldn't get a hold
of one of those.
Sorry--
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --they
wouldn't give me one.
Never mind.
But if you do win, then
we will swag you.
We will swag you good.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You're all
quite dazzled by that.
I thought you might not, so I
thought I'd go all in and,
like, yeah!
Look at that stuff!
A neon thing, a glass.
Have you see one of
those before?
And a cup, brilliant.
OK.
The lens flares are
sold separately.
Sorry about that.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Let's
get started.
We're going to start off really
simple, like images in
HTML right?
You've done that before.
Fair enough.
OK, here is a div.
The div has a source,
like an image might.
Which browsers do you think
are going to make
a request for that?
Now, on your phones and your
laptops, at the moment, it
should have given you the
options for this question.
If it hasn't, just
hit refresh.
And you should get them.
Now, when we we're talking about
these browsers, we're
talking about the latest version
of them, the latest
stable release.
You get one point for each
one you get right.
And you will lose a point for
each one you get wrong.
So if you say Firefox doesn't
make a request, and it does,
you will lose a point there.
You can assume the
HTML5 doc type.
And there's nothing funky in the
head, like a base tag that
might throw things off.
There's no trickery going on.
And what you're seeing here is a
live read out of the opinion
of the room.
So the needle will swing one
way when you think yes.
It will swing the other way when
you think no, although
the direction is randomized
for each question.
So you cannot just go
along with the room.
You will be probably getting
it wrong if you do that.
All right.
OK, that's probably
enough time.
If you haven't answered,
yet, answer quickly.
Because I'm going to close the
question in three, two, one.
And OK, so the needle's going
roughly in the middle, which
means collectively you
don't have a clue.
Well done, everyone.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You were kind
of thinking, yes in--
well, most of the browsers,
kind of more strongly in
Internet Explorer.
It's almost like you'd
been bitten by that
browser in the past.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: The answer
is, of course, no.
Not in any of the browsers.
None of them are going
to do that.
Well done, the people that got
it right, four people by the
sounds of things.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Excellent,
well done.
But this is not as
mad as it seems.
So in XHTML2, you
could do this.
You could have any elements,
such as a div with a source,
and the browser would replace
that element with the content
of that resource.
And it was kind of
a good idea.
It was the start of a good idea
because you could take
rich semantic content and
replace it with an image.
It made the Alt attribute
completely redundant.
Pretty cool.
But XHTML2 had the backwards
incompatibility issues.
And it carried with it XML's
Draconian error-handling.
And once you invite XML into
your home, it XMLs everything.
It XMLs all over the carpet,
up the walls.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And in the same
way that smurfs stick the
word "smurf" in front of
everything to make it a smurf
thing, XML sticks X at the
start of everything.
You don't want HTML.
You want XHTML.
You don't want frames.
You want Xframes.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You
don't want forms.
You can have Xforms.
If you let XML take over your
life, it will turn your
boyfriend or girlfriend into an
X-boyfriend or girlfriend.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And "XMLcool"
with that.
Because you don't
need a partner.
Because you've got XML to
look after you now.
Things fitting that, in
2009, XHTML2 became an
X-specification.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We didn't
care about it anymore.
And no browsers ever implemented
source on
something like a div.
But what about this?
We've got an image element.
It's got a source.
Which browser is going
to make a request?
Now, notice that I have spelled
image incorrectly, in
terms of HTML.
Does the browser treat this
like an unknown element?
Or does it do something
special?
We saw XML was too Draconian,
too strict for the web.
But is HTML this lenient?
Or are the browsers more
lenient than the
spec in this case?
So we're seeing you're kind of
leaning towards one way.
And pretty much all
the browsers--
ah, you're changing your
mind and going
back into the middle.
We're going to keep this
rolling quickly.
So just make a decision.
I'm going to close the question
in three, two, one.
And it's closed.
So you're kind of thinking,
pretty much,
yes, in all the browsers.
And you would be absolutely
correct.
In all of them--
AUDIENCE: Yay!
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --it will make
a request for the image.
And note, in these situations,
it doesn't
have to show the image.
We're just talking about
making a request.
But in this case, all of the
browsers will actually show
the image as well.
You see, back in the past--
I don't know if you remember
the past-- but one browser
decided that IMG was too
difficult for developers to
remember, and that image
should work as well.
And we've been stuck with
that ever since.
Now, which browser vendor
do you think we have
to blame for this?
Oh, yes, of course, it is--
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --Mosaic--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --back
in 1993.
The people who invented the
image tag, they did this.
And a study in 2005 showed that,
like, 0.2% of pages were
using this incorrectly
spelled image.
So all the browsers have to
support it for pretty much
forevermore.
The WhatWG recognized this
and added it to the spec.
This is the parsing spec.
And you can see there, start
tag, if it's image, change the
token name to IMG and
reprocess it.
Don't ask, right?
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But recently,
I-M-A-G-E was using the kind
of a clever hack, Alexei
Ten came up with this.
So you would use this on your
page instead of an image, this
block of sort of SVG with
an image inside it.
And what it'll do is it will
show an SVG and in browsers
that support SVG.
And it will do a PNG
in other browsers.
So a modern browser will
parse it like this.
Ah, OK.
That's an SVG element.
OK, it's going to
be 100 by 100.
That's fine.
Oh, and this is an SVG image.
Because in SVG, image elements
are spelled fully--
I-M-A-G-E. Oh, it's got
a width and a height.
That's great.
And I'm going to load img.svg.
Because this is how you define
the source for an image in SVG
because it's part of XML.
And why have a link, when
you can have an Xlink?
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And then,
it sees this.
And it goes, [RASPBERRY SOUND].
That mean absolutely nothing
to SVG images, so I'm
going to ignore it.
Whereas an older browser, maybe
the Android 2, IE8,
they'll parse it like this.
Neh, eer-a--
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --ffyya, er, I
mean, going to ignore that.
Oh, look, the developer
spelled "image" wrong.
OK, I am going to use that.
It's 100 by 100.
Pha-pe-ffff-ha!
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Whoa!
Developer got high.
I'm going to ignore that.
And I'm going to load img.png.
It's great.
So this doesn't require
JavaScript, and you're
switching between the
two image formats.
And we got kind of excited
about it, and we started
tweeting about it.
The mistake we made is
we didn't test it.
So a few of us started
testing it.
And we found something
interesting.
All of these browsers
support SVG.
Which ones download
both images?
They shouldn't.
And I'll give you a clue--
it doesn't go one way or the
other for all browsers.
Some of the browsers are
doing it differently.
So you're going to have to pick
the browser or browsers
that you think get this
wrong because not all
of them get it wrong.
I'm going to close
the question.
Ho-ho.
[LAUGHS]
Oh, dear.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, no, OK.
We've got some IE fans
in the room.
Closing the question
in three, two, one.
OK, so you're edging towards
Internet Explorer being the
bad guy here.
And in this case,
you are correct.
As a kind of group, you're
doing quite well.
You should all form a company
or something.
It's great.
So all the browsers here, all
the latest versions, they have
two parsers inside, a relatively
new thing for
browsers to have.
But these ones, they
all have it.
One parser runs ahead as quickly
as it can and picks up
things that it should download,
like images,
scripts, all that
sort of stuff.
The other parser does the heavy
lifting like building
the DOM tree, and parsing
scripts, and all that stuff.
This has a surprisingly
large benefit.
You know, Ilya is posting
about this.
This study that was done
through 2,000 sites.
And it had a 20% speed
improvement.
That's pretty incredible.
That's time to get DOM
content loaded.
In order to be quick, this other
pre-parser, this first
one is a little bit stupid.
In Internet Explorer, it's that
little bit too stupid,
and it kind of gets
overexcited.
And it's like, I'm going
to show a PNG!
I'm going to show a PNG!
Yep, here I go!
I'm going to show the PNG!
Here it goes!
Naw, actually, no.
It's an SVG--
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --nevermind.
Fair enough.
It kind of sees the image.
But it misses the SVG context.
So it picks up the
wrong source.
And then the main parser comes
along and goes, pppfff, what
are you doing?
No, this is an SVG thing, and
downloads the correct thing.
The moral here is if there's
some kind of performance
advice going on, don't just
blindly trust it.
In Chrome we say, use
tools, not rules.
And it rhymes.
So it must be true, right?
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But also be on
the lookout for existing
tests, if someone has done the
leg work for you, and you can
just run that test yourself.
One of my favorite stories in
science involves this guy
August Weismann.
He wanted to disprove that
evolution was learned.
Like if you had some kind of
life experience, that that
would be passed to
your children.
He wanted to disprove that was
a thing because it wasn't the
Darwin evolution.
So he took some mice, and he
cut their tails off, and he
bred them together.
And then the next generation,
he cut their tails off and
bred them together as well.
And the theory was, well, if
evolution is learned, we're
going to start getting mice
born without tails.
And he was quite a way into this
research until someone
went, uh, you do realize,
August, that the Jewish people
have been carrying out
this test a lot
longer than you have?
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And ay-uh-uhh!
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Fair
enough, yeah, OK.
Job done.
So yeah, don't reinvent the
wheel unless you want to learn
a lot about wheels.
And that could be
cool sometime.
OK, what about this?
I've got an image.
It's inside a div that
is displaying.
Not in this image.
It's not going to
be displayed.
But which browsers are going
to request the URL and
download the image regardless?
So I did it quickly.
We're going to go for, oh, are
we still thinking IE is going
to do something different?
People are thinking Firefox
is going to
do something different.
I'm going to close the question
in three, two, one.
There we go.
The countdown is going
to get old.
But I'm going to do it for
every question anyway.
OK, so, we're sort of saying,
yes in IE, maybe no in Safari,
no in Chrome, and maybe
in Firefox.
The answer is yes
in all of them.
They're all going to download
the image in this case.
And this behavior is part of
this specification as well.
In the beginning, there
is nothing, right?
And then the browser gets
sprayed with HTML text.
And then from that, it is going
to construct this tree
of elements that, as
Paul was explaining
earlier, is the DOM.
When one of these things is
constructed, the constructor
steps for that element
are run.
And if we look at the spec for
image, it's quite complicated
for what you would think would
be a very simple thing.
But this is the image stuff.
They all run synchronously,
step 14, fetch the image.
No mention of CSS.
No mention of anything
like that.
And that's good in some ways
because it means the browser
can start the image downloading
before the CSS is there.
The pre-parser can
deal with it.
Downside is, well, we couldn't
do polyfills for things like
responsive images.
Because by the time JavaScript
gets there to do something
clever, the image has already
started downloading, and
you're just going to trigger
a second request by
changing the source.
This won't be a problem
in the future.
+The resource is priority
spec, has this postpone
attribute, which means the image
won't download if it's
Display None.
And it allows the browser to
avoid downloading it, even if
it's just outward view
on the page as well.
So you don't have to rely on
these heavy scroll events for
image lazy loading.
OK, what if we're using CSS?
Does visibility matter then?
What about this?
Once again, that image is not
going to be displayed because
it's inside an element
that is Display None.
So we saw here that the image
would download in this case.
But what about in CSS?
Is it going to do something
different?
Does visibility matter here?
Are some of the browsers going
to do something different?
I'm going to close the question
in three, two, one.
Oh!
Going right to the middle.
Collectively, once
again, no clue.
Don't worry about it, guys.
It's quite difficult.
What's the answer?
None of the browsers will
make a request here.
And that's kind of
cool, right?
We want to be able to rely
on that kind of behavior.
Slightly different one.
What about now?
Same thing again.
Image is not going to be
rendered because it's on a
Display None element.
But it's not inside a Display
None element.
It is on the Display
So we saw the browsers weren't
downloading before.
What about now?
Did the browsers do something
different?
Did they all download it?
Did they all not download it?
I mean, they don't need it.
It's not going to be rendered.
I'm going to close
the question and
three, two, one, done.
All right.
We're saying no in pretty
much every browser.
Most browsers will download
it in this case.
Only Firefox won't.
So what's going on here?
Well, once you've got some DOM
elements on the page, as Paul
was explaining before, they are
going to get their styles
calculated, where the browser
goes to see which of your
cascaded styles of your
font tags-- if
you're from the '90s--
which styles apply to each
element individually.
But not everything gets
it's style calculated.
So you've got these two elements
at the bottom.
No style calculation.
And the reason is this div at
the top here turned out to be
Display None.
And the browser shortcuts,
because it knows the styles of
these elements have no impact on
the rendering of the page.
So it doesn't bother.
It takes a shortcut.
So if these have background
images, the browser never
finds out about it.
If the Display None element has
a background image, the
browser does find
out about it.
And that's why we see most
browsers downloading it, at
that point.
Firefox is a little
bit smarter here.
But if you use something like
Visibility Hidden or Opacity
Zero, Firefox will be
downloading as well.
Who's getting it right
according to the
specification?
Everyone is!
It's great.
So the specification says
absolutely nothing about this.
Because this tiny note that says
the browser may optimize.
It may avoid downloading images
that are out of view,
even if there's another
element over the top.
The browser may avoid
downloading at this point.
No browsers are that
smart yet.
This kind of freedom in the
specifications is great.
Because it means the browser can
do what's right, given the
situation, and the kind of
device, and the network
connectivity, et cetera,
et cetera.
But it's also kind of scary
because this is where you're
going to get the browsers
doing different
things, as we saw here.
But I kind of like that.
I think that's the diversity
that makes the web great.
It's not one company
driving forward
with its own interests.
It's lots of companies driving
forward in different
directions.
And we get this sort
of car crash.
But a car crash with
a happy ending!
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And that's the
web that we have today.
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So if you want
to avoid downloading
backgrounds and CSS, hiding
element isn't enough.
You need to put it inside
something that is hidden.
So the browser won't find or
even look at that element.
But when you do that, realize
you are relying on just what
the browsers do.
It is not specs behavior.
The only sure-fire way is don't
let the browser find out
about the background image.
Take the class off until you
need it, or don't put the
element in the DOM until
you need it.
All right.
Things have been quite
easy, so far.
Let's get JavaScript involved.
What do you think?
Creating an image element,
once again, I've spelled
"image" wrong.
I'm applying a source to it.
It is not in the document.
So it's not going to
be displayed yet.
And it's spelled wrong.
We saw the browsers correcting
for that before.
But that was in HTML.
What about in the DOM?
Is that going to be different?
I'm going to close the question
in three, two, one.
All right, done.
OK, so we're edging towards
yes, in most browsers.
It is yes in most browsers,
except Firefox.
Firefox does something
different here.
And there are two parts
to this explanation.
We saw before that the DOM
builds up, and these creation
steps for elements are run.
But even if you create the
elements, and it's not part of
a document, that's still going
to run those creation steps.
And we saw before, step
14, fetch the image.
We can use this to our advantage
because you can make
a GET request to any URL by
making an image element and
assigning a source.
And you could use the image
element constructor.
It's a tiny bit of code.
You can make a request
anywhere.
This is kind of how Google
Analytics communicates back to
the server.
Oh, yeah, but Firefox didn't
make a request.
So what's going on there?
It's because we spelled
"image" wrong.
And most browsers, Chrome,
Safari, IE will give us an
HTML image element
when we do that.
Firefox will give us
an HTML element.
It's not an image.
You add it to the page.
It will not show an image.
And you know what?
It's the only one getting
it right.
We saw before that the
specification says, if you
encounter a start tag,
you can correct it.
But this is the parsing spec.
We bypass the parsing spec by
creating the element in
JavaScript.
So yeah, actually, technically,
it should have
returned an HTML unknown
element.
But it's getting closer to right
than the other browsers.
I think I preferred it when the
web with all the browsers,
like, there was one bad guy,
and all the other browsers
seemed perfect.
It was like an orchestra, and
Internet Explorer 8 was just
this screaming child hitting
two cymbals together.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But then we
finally got rid of the
screaming child with the cymbal,
and then we started
conducting again.
And we went, oh, actually
everyone's out of tune.
We just didn't notice, because
of the screaming cymbal child.
Oh, fair enough.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: All right, let's
get CSS involved again.
What about this?
So as before, creating a div,
I'm going to give it a
background image.
So I'm not creating an image.
Creating a div, giving it
a background image.
We saw, here, that images would
download at this point.
Is it different with CSS?
Do different browsers
do different stuff?
So we are edging towards
the don't know.
Oh, wow!
It sort of swung
the other way.
Closing the question
in three, two, one.
All right, so we're edging
towards yes in everything.
Wrong-uns, the lot of you.
No browser will download here.
And this is kind of the same
as the Display None case.
It's not in the document.
So the browser is not going to
go looking for the styles,
because it doesn't need to know
the style information,
because it knows it's
not going to render.
All right, going to be cruel.
Same thing, but I'm going
to add it to the DOM.
And then, I'm going
to take it away.
In the same block of JavaScript,
will the browser
see that element in the document
long enough to
actually trigger the download?
What do you think?
I'm going to close the question
in three, two, one.
We're edging towards
yes in everything.
Wrong again.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: None
of the browsers.
None of them.
The browser doesn't think about
styles or layout until
as late as possible, which
normally means when it needs
to render something.
And this isn't going to change
any pixels because JavaScript
is going to be blocking the
chance to do some of that
painting stuff.
What about this?
I'm adding it to the document.
I'm going to ask for
it's text content.
It's an empty element.
Text content is going
to be empty as well.
And then, I'm going to
remove it again.
Does that trigger different
behavior in the browser?
Element is completely
empty so, you know.
But is that going to trigger the
browser to go, oh, yeah,
I'm actually going to get
that background image.
I'm going to close the question
in three, two, one.
What have you said?
Aaah, you don't know.
Fair enough.
Yes, it's tricky.
No.
None of the browsers
at this point.
I am going somewhere
with this.
I promise you.
Getting the text content of
an element is pretty easy.
It's just going to go and
pick up the text nodes.
It doesn't need to look at
the style or anything.
What about this one?
InnerHTML?
Same as before.
But instead of text content,
I'm going to
ask for the old innerHTML.
Oh, wow!
IE is doing something different
to everyone else.
Interesting.
I'm going to close the question
in three, two, one.
All right, so, you've said
yes in IE, and no
in everything else.
Bloody hell.
You're right.
Well done.
IE makes the request.
And the reason for
that is because--
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Some things in
the world cannot be explained,
like why it takes three attempts
to plug in a USB
cable, even though there's
only two possibilities.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: These things
just cannot be explained.
Moving on.
Similar again.
Instead of HTML,
it's innerText.
What do the browsers do here?
Do they do something
different?
We saw IE is quite request-happy
with innerHTML.
Does it do something different
with innerText?
Does it trigger a requests in
any of the other browsers?
I promise you, I am going
somewhere with this.
Closing the question
in three, two, one.
There's quite a strong opinion
of no across all the browsers.
Sorry, guys.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes, in
everything except Firefox.
And this actually makes sense.
Let's make a div.
We make a div.
We get a background image.
I'm going to give it innerHTML,
where it's got,
Hello, World.
And the div is a div around
the world or whatever.
Text content is "Hello World,"
as you might expect.
The innerText has a
line break in it.
And this is how it is in
IE, Chrome, and Safari.
Because innerText is more like
what you would get if you copy
and pasted the text
of the elements.
And because div is a block level
element or so it is in
this example, it gets
a new line.
So if we run this, the browser
goes, yeah, yeah, yeah, text
content, easy enough,
innerText.
Oh, innerText is style
dependent.
So I'm going to have a look at
the styles of the element.
And, oh, it's got a
background image.
That's interesting.
I'll download that.
And that's why we see most
browsers doing it.
Firefox doesn't download at this
point because it doesn't
support innerText.
It's the only browser
that doesn't.
So it just returns undefined
at that point.
But if you used any of these,
apart from innerText, like,
anything that's going to get
some style data from the page,
Firefox would have started
the download as well.
So Paul was talking about
this earlier.
You can start doing layout
thrashing if you start doing
these reads and writes.
You'll trigger extra
layouts, et cetera.
The browser is quite clever
about this stuff.
It will batch changes
together.
Like if you do this, like,
Display None, Block None,
Block, et cetera, et cetera,
Loads of Width, this is
actually a really light
piece of code.
It's not tricky for the browser
to understand because
it's going to ignore--
all right, I hope that's not
my cue to get off because
that's very passive
aggressive.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Anyway, so, it
will just take the last change
that you make.
Oh, that's nice.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: This is great.
But it can lead to unexpected
results.
Let's have a look at a
practical example.
Paul and I, we want
to go over there.
You can tell because
we're pointing.
Let's do it with code.
We're going to start
at left zero.
We're going to transition left
one second, go to 100%.
We run that code, and it works.
Yay!
We solved the world's
problems with code.
Now, we're very happy
at this point.
But let's run the code again.
Nothing happened.
And this is because the browser
is going to ignore
this first right of left.
It's just going to batch
them together.
It's only going to listen to
our last-- right here.
And it's 100%.
We're at 100% already.
So nothing happens.
We can fix this by forcing a
synchronous layout here.
Because that forces the browser
to go and look at all
the styles of all the elements
in the page.
And it realizes, oh, yeah,
we are supposed
to be at left zero.
So when we make the
next changes, it
will start from zero.
And we can run this code as
many times as we want.
And it works.
You might have encountered
this kind of behavior and
tried to use set timeout or
something to get around it.
No, you can just force
a layout like this.
Right.
OK, last question.
Let's go through this quickly.
Because I'm going to
be chucked off the
stage in a few seconds.
Imagine a page full
of Lorem Ipsum.
It looks like this--
595 pixels across; media query,
min-width 600 min-width.
So we wouldn't really be
expecting it to display.
Which browsers are going to
download that gif, anyway?
Are the browsers going to
do something different?
I'm going to say, would
we expect it to even
display that gif?
Who knows.
Last question, so make
it a good one.
Closing it in three, two, one.
Straight down the middle.
I feel like I've broken
you as an audience.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm
very sorry.
What happens here?
IE and Firefox will download,
and they will actually display
the background as well.
And this is quite sneaky.
My measurement did not include
the scrollbar.
With the scrollbar, it brings
it over 600 pixels.
Now, yeah, they don't call
me Cunning Jake--
they don't actually call
me Cunning Jake.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: This seems
insane to me, to include the
scrollbar width!
What if the user has a 200
megapixels scrollbar?
Why should I care about that?
But including the scroll
bar is mandated by the
specification.
It's interesting.
And Chrome and Safari are
breaking the spec here.
It's fixed in the Chrome
nightlies.
It's not fixed in the
WebKit nightlies.
Why is the scrollbar included?
Well, imagine this
bit of code.
I'm forcing no scrollbar.
And then when the width gets to
600, I'm going to introduce
a scrollbar.
500 pixels, that's fine.
We get to 601, ah, we need
to put a scrollbar in.
Oh, now we're less
than 600 pixels.
We'll take it away.
And so on--
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --and
so on, and so on.
In reality, it doesn't
get stuck in a loop.
But here, we can see
what Safari does.
I've got a background picture
and a scrollbar coming in at a
particular width.
And we'll see, I'm only
making it bigger.
I'm not moving both ways.
And we can see--
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --that
the background image
flickers on and off.
And then once we get beyond the
width of the scrollbar, it
stabilizes.
And that's it.
Let's have a look
at the rankings.
Don't worry.
If you haven't scored great,
it won't actually show your
name on the screen.
It's only going to
show the top 10.
So don't worry too much.
Here we've got
prettyFlyForAWiFi.
Very good.
Who's that?
[CHEERS]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Excellent.
Right, I will swag you
good and proper.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh,
god, you've done
really, really well.
OK, that's my time up.
Thank you very much, guys.
Cheers, bye.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: Jake, here's
our special gift for you.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, thank
you very much.
PETER LUBBERS: A little
bit more.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, thank you.
Cheers now.
[CHUCKLES]
Right, I'm going to run away.
PETER LUBBERS: I'm sorry.
You've got all the swag?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes.
I will catch up with
you in a bit.
And we'll do the swag thing.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Cool, right.
PETER LUBBERS: That's
pretty good.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETER LUBBERS: We're
also hiring.
[CHUCKLES]
All right.
OK, well, thank you, Jake.
We're just switching laptops.
Just a quick idea
on the timeline.
We have another 25-minute
talk.
And then we have a
very short break.
Maybe 10 minutes, just to reset
the video, and so on.
And then, we'll have a Q&A
discussion until 9:30.
At which point, we'll
start with
raffling off all the goodies.
All right, so next up, we have
Paul Irish, who is also a
repeat speaker, here,
at SFHTML5.
Happy to have you back, Paul.
And Paul's a developer advocate
in the Chrome
Developer Relations team,
focusing mostly
on developer tools.
And I think we'll see a lot
more about that next.
OK, we're doing a little
sound-- oh, yeah.
Do you have the one?
Ah-ha.
We're trying to get these
monitors to work.
They all worked in
the pre-test.
And they stopped working.
Again, a couple of events
that are coming up.
Chrome Developer Summit,
November 20 and 21.
It'll be in Mountain View
at the quad, the
Google office there.
We will be live streaming
that event as well.
There are about 300 people
that can fit in
the building there.
Registration will
open in October.
We'll post some things
about that.
HTML5 DevCon happening the week
of October 20, training
sessions followed by a
two-day conference.
And then two days of training
on top of that.
Very, very reasonably priced, so
definitely, check that out.
And--
[CHUCKLES]
Well, you're going to have
the mic on there.
All right.
PETER LUBBERS: Are those
screens working, or no?
OK.
PAUL IRISH: That's cool.
We'll--
all right.
Yeah, that seems almost
workable, yeah?
MALE SPEAKER: Better.
PAUL IRISH: Hey--
MALE SPEAKER: There you go.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
This is nice.
Oh, yeah.
There you go.
Still loading, huh.
It's kind of aggravating
to look at, isn't it?
It's just like, come on!
Uh.
Yeah, OK.
So let's start.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about the tools that are
available to identify and
improve some of the things
that we actually saw tonight.
And so to start off, I want
to separate some of the
performance ideas into
two separate buckets.
If this works for you guys.
I don't know.
It seems kind of OK.
The user experience of
performance is mostly separate
into two things, like, give me
the damn thing that I wanted.
And now that I have it,
I want to interact
with it really nicely.
So in "give me the damn thing
I wanted," it's page load,
often abbreviated as PLT,
Page Load Time.
In here, we're talking about
things like the network
waterfall; getting image assets
that are appropriately
sized; non-blocking delivery of
all of our assets; getting
the CSS that we need to render
the top of the page quickly,
and not much else;
and also fonts.
Can we see the text quickly?
When we're talking about runtime
performance, we're
talking about, like, I want
to interact with the page.
I want to click a button and
see that response very
quickly, any sort of
transitions, animations.
When I'm scrolling, does
it stick to my finger?
Like, I am scrolling with my
finger on the device, and it
should just be moving,
immediately, with things, what
we heard about with memory leaks
and garbage collection,
and also Java-based innovation,
like with the
requestAnimationFrame.
But to show a little bit more
about this stuff, I want to
take an example.
So we're going to start
off with a demo.
This is a site for a festival
in Canada, and it's the
Canadian National Exhibition.
So we're actually just going
to go over to the site now,
the live site.
And we're going to
play around.
I'm actually going to do it
here in Chrome Canary.
OK, cool.
So how's this look?
Oh, it's two-eyed.
OK, yeah, seems good.
So Canadian National
Exhibition.
My friend, Mike Taylor,
who works for
Firefox, found this site.
And he said, I defy you to find
a site that is jankier in
its scroll.
And I was like, oh, I know
of a site, actually.
So like, this one.
What is it?
Exception?
Inception?
Inception Explained, is it?
Is this it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: It's really bad.
So Paul mentioned parallax
sites before.
Parallax sites can get into
trouble really fast.
And this side is so cool.
But the frame rate on this
is just so poor.
It's rough.
But let me go back to what
I was talking about.
So Canadian National
Exhibition.
So here we are.
And we got some things
happening.
We've got this laying in
the background, full
bleed in the back.
This header that kind of scrolls
up as I go down.
But let's actually look at the
tools to see what we're
talking about.
So first thing, I'm just going
to turn off this debug mode I
had on earlier.
And always, first thing,
go to timeline.
Start recording.
I use Command E. And we just
scroll up and down, OK.
So we're seeing a
lot of activity
already, a lot of stuff.
We're seeing mostly
purple, right?
I'm scrolling in on this area,
just to get a better zoom.
And it looks like recalc style
is consuming a lot of each of
these frames.
So OK, recalc style.
Some things could
be happening.
I'm not really sure what.
So we hover on the item.
And we can see the JavaScript
call sect that's
associated with this.
So the last thing that happened
was here, inside
removeClass, inside jQuery.
OK, so I'm going to click that,
just to find out what
exactly it was.
We're minified here.
OK, we'll pretty print
down at the bottom.
Looks good.
Now, I'm going to come
back and just
repeat that click again.
OK, cool.
So now we just repeat the click,
and it brings me to the
exact place.
I really like it when the cursor
does it's pretty thing.
So I'm like, aah, yeah!
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL IRISH: So it brings me
right to the class name
assignment.
So there's a setting in the
class name, on an element.
And that is what triggered
the recalc style.
OK, it's good to know.
Now, let's find out
why that happened.
We look down into
the user code.
And so, here, we go
inside CNE.js.
Let me try clicking that,
once again, line 33--
aah, ooh, aah.
Remember how Paul might have
mentioned, do as little as you
can inside your scroll
handlers.
So inside their scroll handler,
they get the height
of the window, the scroll top.
They do a little bit of math.
And then they toggle some
classes on the HTML element in
every single scroll--
toggle, toggle, toggle,
toggle.
Not great.
Certainly, not great.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL IRISH: But we can
make this better.
So the best way to do this
is-- you can see it's a
conditional toggle
class, right?
You're using this second
argument, inside jQuery.
It's a toggle class.
They conditionally change
it, depending on that
math working out.
So that's OK.
So ideally, you set this in an
if block, and you only touch
the DOM if you satisfy
that requirement.
That makes a bit more sense.
We could, actually, cheat
things a little bit.
So I'm just going to edit the
JavaScript right here.
Oh, one sec.
This is OK.
All right, I'm going to edit
the JavaScript right here.
So I'm just going
to backspace--
oh, come on.
All right, cool.
And we're just going to get
the DOM element itself.
And then we're going to use
class list from HTML5.
And it turns out, class list
toggle actually has the exact
same method signature as
jQuery's toggle class.
And now, I'm just going to hit
command S. And Chrome is just
going to update that function,
on the fly,
which is pretty cool.
So now we're going to go back
to timeline, and I'll start
recording again, and
repeat my action.
Yeah!
AUDIENCE: Yay!
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
Pretty sweet.
So here we are.
We do not have massive
recalc style anymore.
But we do have some green
paint going on.
Hmm.
Now, on this device, I'm still
hitting mostly 60 FPS.
So that's kind of OK.
But on mobile devices, I
certainly wouldn't be.
I want to see if I
can do anything
about this paint first.
So first things first, I'm going
to come over into the
settings and turn on Show
Panit Rectangles.
And usually, when I do this,
I like to turn on Show
Composited Layer Borders
at the same time.
They kind of go hand in hand.
So bring DevTools down
a little bit.
And now, I'm just going
to scroll up and down.
So my paint recs are in red.
And we're seeing things.
A lot going on, but I can
definitely see up top, this
section, the header is
just in red non-stop.
Now, the reason why is because
the header is position fixed,
and the content is moving
beneath it.
But that's not going to work.
So it's basically repainting
this, even
though it really shouldn't.
It knows what that looks
like, right?
So the trick here is what?
What's the fix for this
fixed-position element?
AUDIENCE: Translate z.
PAUL IRISH: Ooh!
Yeah!
Translate z, there it is!
I'm excited to type it, and
then I also dread it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: It's like a
combination of things, really.
OK.
WebKit, transform,
translate z.
Ah, my friend.
Some people do the 3D version.
But then you have to do, zero,
comma, zero, comma.
This is my favorite.
So I got that in.
I promoted the layer.
And in fact, there is
now this little gold
border around the top.
And if I just toggle this, you
can see that gold border
coming on and off because
that is now a layer.
All right, so we're going
to put it back on.
And if I scroll up
here-- oh, cool.
Yeah we do not paint that.
But then, we get about
here, and it moves.
And we see that paint.
So let's fix this.
So the movement is here.
We just move the top.
Now, what's probably a better
way of moving this top other
than just changing position
absolute if we
want to move an element?
AUDIENCE: Translate.
PAUL IRISH: Translate.
Yeah, sounds good.
Let's do a transform
translate.
So WebKit and Blink still
have prefixed transform.
So we will do that, hop over
here, and do a translate y.
And that seems to work.
And since I have a CSS
transition down here, I should
probably update that.
Ah, OK.
Now that's a bit nicer.
I still do see red, hmm.
Let's see if-- ahh, yes.
Is that right?
You know.
Aah, ooh, aah!
And I don't know if it feels
smoother to you.
But it feels smoother to me.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL IRISH: It feels good.
All right, so that's
pretty good.
And let's take a look over
in the timeline.
All right, cool.
So in general, in the middle,
we got nothing going on.
We got a little bit of paint
when I'm going between the top
or when the new image
is coming in.
That's pretty good.
So that's a little bit of things
that we can do inside
the DevTools.
I actually made a video
showing taking
this all the way.
The background has
a fixed position.
And we can actually move that
to the body element and get
some wins there.
But I'm going to come back
to my slides first.
Ah, yeah.
All right, so, I want to walk
through some of those
operations that we
were seeing.
Recalc style, so, what's
happening inside recalc style
is it is getting all the style
rules that affect the page.
This is anything inside a style
sheet, an in-line style,
the user-agent style sheet.
It's getting all the
style rules.
It's bringing them into
an object model.
Then it takes all those
selectors that you got hanging
around and matches those against
what's in the DOM.
And it says, oh, there it is.
That one right there,
yes, uh-huh.
The selector matching.
Now, as Paul said, it
happens really fast.
Usually in recalc style, the
selector matching takes up
about 10% of the general
purple bar.
Not very much.
Don't worry about it.
Now, that it has that and
matched against the DOM, it
calculates the computed style
for every single DOM element.
So you know in JavaScript,
when you ask for a GET
computed style?
It's doing that.
But for every CSS property, for
every element, it figures
out how things should look.
It makes sense.
OK, moving on into layout.
Layout is the geometry
of the page.
And I want to show one way
to look at layout.
So I'll open up this little
demo right here.
And--
come on.
JSbin's server is in
the UK, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
It's like looking at
a loaded spinner.
All right, cool.
So I'm going to click these
buttons like that.
Now, what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to hit switch layout.
And we're going to start
this animation.
Now, if I open up Timeline and
record, you can see that, as
that animation's happening,
we're getting a
lot of layout costs.
And that makes sense because
layout is reevaluating the
geometry of the page.
And this sort of animation here
has to figure out this
new text flow.
And when the text flows, then we
get a new height for where
person two starts and
person three starts.
And it's a lot of work to figure
out that new geometry.
And it happens every single
frame of that animation.
It's a bit expensive.
Now, the next thing after layout
is determined is paint.
We heard a lot about
this from Paul.
Paint hurts a lot on
low-end devices.
Old Android phones with not a
lot of hardware have a tough
time updating anything when it
requires paint on every frame.
Debugging this with continuous
paint mode is probably one of
the best ways to do it.
So I'm going to show
that real quickly.
I said real quickly.
And then, I loaded
up a JSbin URL.
Come on, England.
Come to me, the bits.
All right.
Handy trick--
DevTools at the bottom, you
might like it on the right.
You can just take the bar here
and drag it up to the--
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL IRISH: You can also
click the button.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL IRISH: Great.
I have a lot of DevTool
extensions, and I'm just going
to make excuses.
You might have noticed inside of
Chrome Canary that I have--
wow.
Let's go back.
So we're here.
We're looking at this page.
We have lovely boxes
all over the place.
That's real good.
But we're going to turn on
continuous paint mode.
Now, continuous paint
mode, basically,
says to Chrome, hey.
I know you know what
it looks like.
But I just want you to tell me
what it looks like, again, and
again, and again, and
again, and again.
So it's just going to repaint
everything that
needs to get painted.
So if I look at Timeline, it
is just doing the same work
over and over again.
But what this allows us to do
is make some changes and see
how it affects that
graph up there.
So right now we're
looking at--
what is this?
8 milliseconds or so per paint
of the entire page.
Now, we can try some
different things.
So maybe I'm going to
come over here and
toggle the box shadows.
So I turn on box shadows.
And you can see pretty quickly--
sorry about that--
paint time dives really,
really high.
So the box shadow is adding
quite a bit to how long it
takes to paint the page.
I also know that there's a
border radius on these boxes.
I can try turning that off.
See if that makes
any difference.
It does make a slight
difference, yeah.
But this gives you an option
to figure out things.
Now, a handy trick when you're
using continuous painting mode
is the H key hides
DOM elements.
So you can walk through you're
DOM, hide things and see what
the effect is.
So maybe you'll hide
the header, get
that out of the way.
It bisects the DOM, figuring
out where your costs are.
This H works all the time.
It's pretty handy.
So that's continuous painting
mode real quick.
I got a question recently which
is, there's all these
operations inside the
DevTools timeline.
What is the order that
I should see them in?
And then what we're looking at
right here is basically it.
So a lot of times, you start
off with some JavaScript.
It touches the DOM.
It changes something.
Then the browser does have
to recalculate style.
It has to layout the page.
It has to paint it and probably
composite some layers.
Ideally, this is the flow.
And there's only one operation
per, basically, paint.
Paint is the user got
to see something.
When we were talking about
layout thrashing before,
layout thrashing is, oftentimes,
we're doing a
bunch of recalc style and then
layout, and then recalc style
and layout, recalc
style and layout.
And the user doesn't
see anything.
There are no paints.
So ideally, you have only
one layout per paint.
So here's a little cheat sheet
for taking action from what
the timeline is telling you.
If the timeline is telling
you, oh my
god, lots of yellow.
There's so much time being
spent inside JavaScript.
I should point out that that
Canadian expo site, remember
when I profiled it before?
Was there any yellow
at all in it?
No.
There was no JavaScript at all
slowing down that site.
It was all inside
the rendering.
But if you're in a case where
you are on a lot of
JavaScript, you can use
the flame chart.
I'm going to show this
really quickly.
Who has seen or used
the flame chart?
It's good.
It's a powerful thing.
So this is MathJax
and a really good
polyfill for MathML.
But I want to check out
how fast it can
render these things.
So I'm going to turn
off these.
Come down here.
And so it's actually just
rendering this stuff out.
And I can choose to render
it in SVG or HML CSS.
Come under Profiles, and I'm
going to collect JavaScript
CPU profiles and record.
Change this.
Ooh, aah!
All right, cool.
Now, normally when you come into
the JavaScript profile,
you see something like this.
Just go down to the bottom,
right there and
select Flame Chart.
What it's going to give you
is a view like this.
And so, this is a time-based
view of JavaScript execution.
And it progresses from left to
right over time just like you
expect on the timeline.
And in fact, if you want, you
can record on the timeline and
on the JavaScript profiler
at the same time.
But you see some spikes.
You want to go investigate
what's actually happening.
And so, I'll take a look
at the SVG one first.
So we can see there's actually
a good amount of latency.
There's good gaps between
all these flames.
And if you look on timeline,
there's actually a bunch of
network activity that's
happening
between these things.
So they're making network
requests as they're trying to
pull together things.
And it's a bit inefficient.
Over in this version, they
don't have that problem.
But we can identify where
all the function
costs are coming from.
Now, height is just
call stack.
So height is really
not important.
What's important is width
because width is time.
But we're able to see here what
are the functions that
are taking up time.
We also get to understand the
execution code paths here, and
what calls what, and how do we
go from start to finish in
this operation.
So that's if we're spending
a lot of time on Script.
If we're spending a lot of time
in Layout, dig into the
JavaScript that's
triggering it.
In DevTools timeline, like I
showed before, you'll see a
call stack.
Find out what you're doing in
JavaScript that it's forcing
the browser to do a layout.
With Paints, find what is
actually being repainted.
Turn on those paint rects, turn
on the layer borders, and
see what's happening.
You might have to promote a
layer using translate z to get
out of a paint storm.
This often happens with
fixed-position elements.
But take another look at
what Paul showed you.
You can bisect what are actually
expensive things
happening using continuous
paint mode.
And if none of these things
answer your questions, it's
time to dig into About Tracing,
which is a really
extensive tool.
And I'm not going to
touch it right now.
But to tackle all of these
operations and how they
actually map to your CSS,
we should probably
take a look at that.
So if we take this little block
of CSS, the selector up
there-- and that does
have to get
matched up to a DOM element.
So the selector will be caught
up in recalc style.
The height affects the
geometry of the box.
So that is mostly captured
inside the cost of layout.
And a text shadow does not
affect any geometry of the
page whatsoever.
It is just a visual
effect, right?
So it will have no
effect whatsoever
inside Layout and Paint.
Now, this is helpful to know.
Because if you turn on
Continuous Painting mode, it's
only going to give you numbers
that reflect things that have
an effect on paint.
So you change the height of a
box inside Continuous Paint
mode, not much, really.
You're not going to
get a good result.
But another way to look at this
is that different CSS
properties affect these
different things.
So like Paul mentioned before,
transform and opacity are
really fast because the GPU
can handle it 100%.
So this happens here.
If you're touching transform and
opacity, you do not need
to lay these out.
You do not need to paint them.
A few happen at Paint.
So this is box shadow,
border radius.
These are visual effects.
Like I said, they don't
affect any geometry.
Outline is also here.
Because outline is similar
to border.
But you can change an outline
from 1 pixel to 100 pixels,
and everything stays
the same place.
But a lot of CSS properties
do affect the layout.
Of course, anything
that affects the
positioning of the boxes.
Width, margin, border, absolute
positioning, relative
positioning, these things
affect layout.
And actually, I took a look
at all the CSS properties.
So Chrome, actually--
yesterday, I think--
released some numbers around
the popularity of all CSS
properties on the web.
And this is them.
So width is the most popular
CSS property.
Who would have expected that?
But it's interesting to look
at these and identify what
sequence of operations
they force.
And so most actually do affect
the geometry of the page.
But, of course, opacity, like
I mentioned, does not.
Another cool way to look
at this is Animatable.
Lea Verou made this tool.
And hopefully, I can show
this really quickly.
So this is just using key frame
animations, just to
change a single CSS property
on a bunch
of different things.
But it's pretty cool to bring
this up and try it out to see
what it actually looks
like inside Timeline.
So like I said, we'll take
a look at font size.
There we go.
So as we animate font size, font
size does cause layout.
And we see it right here.
Box shadow, like I mentioned,
does not have any effect on
layout and--
oh, did I lie?
Ooh, tough, Paul.
Let me try one more.
There we go.
That's pretty good.
So we're doing a transform
animation.
It's just staying on the GPU.
We're not going back
to layout.
So this is extremely efficient
when it comes to animations.
So in transitions, there's four
things that a browser can
do really, really fast
in jank-free.
It can scale.
It can move, it can
rotate, and fade.
These translate in CSS
to these guys.
I should point out, you
might need the null
transform hack, maybe.
But if you're doing any
animations, any visual
effects, you want to be doing
them with these operations.
These can be fast.
It could be fast on
low-end hardware.
high-end hardware.
Every other operation is going
to incur layout or maybe a
good amount of paint.
So it's going to be slower.
Now, when it comes to measuring,
we want to know
that these performance
enhancements that we're doing
are good for people.
If we take a look at Twitter,
the load event, window
outload, fires about midway
through the network waterfall.
And the end of activity
is quite a bit later.
So looking at window.load for
knowing that the page is done
is not going to work out.
So we need better ways
to identify how
successful are we?
So this is an approach developed
by a guy named Pat
Meenen, who runs WebPageTest.
So up at the top, we have the
filmstrip view of loading a
page that's been optimized
two different ways.
And so, you can see that the
third way is delivering
content to the user faster
than the other ones.
Down here is a plot of the
percentage of the visual
progress, plotting these out.
So you can see, here, we're
already showing
things to the user.
And so, that's why gold
is jumping up.
Now, if we want to take this and
turn it into a metric, we
can take the area above
that line and just
absorb it into a figure.
So this is called
the speed index.
It's basically the area above
the curve that accounts for
the visual progress being
shown to the user.
So this is a nice, quantitative
measurement for
getting a successful picture
in front of the user.
Now, in the real world, we want
to be able to identify
things like, how as we're
developing a project over
time, are we regressing
performance?
Are we improving it?
Adobe Topcoat is a CSS library
that has a really nice
framework set up for
benchmarking.
So they're using a project
called Telemetry that
Chrome works on.
And so, this is actually a view
of their button element.
And the horizontal axis
we just have commits.
And we can actually see--
for the mean frame rate, the
load time, and the layout how
things are progressing.
And so you can actually see
this is a pretty big
regression in load time
of this test case.
And then things actually did
slow down later here as well.
But we're able to track
this over time,
which is really powerful.
Another developer took a look
at this and applied this to
Bootstrap over the history of
the project from 1.0 to 3.0.
And so this is just a quick
view of the dropdowns
component inside Bootstrap.
And we're looking at the
first paint metric.
First paint is a tricky one.
And it's hard to find the good
metrics, but I think speed
index is one of the best ones.
Inside Google Analytics there's
a few tools for these.
You're looking at network
activity.
You can identify page load time,
domain look up, page
download time.
All these are the exact same as
window.performance.timing.
But since all major browsers
support this, Google Analytics
will report it here.
You also get these numbers
split up by browser, by
operating system.
So this is just a view I made of
browsing operating system.
Here, you can see Safari on iOS
is considerably slower on
page load time than the rest.
And I think that's mostly
because it's on a mobile
network, whereas nearly
all these others
are desktop on Wi-Fi.
Speedcurve is a really
cool site.
It's still in private
beta right now.
But it's hoping to give you a
lot more insight when it comes
to the performance of
your site over time.
And so, here is HTMLRocks--
which I work on--
plotted against Amazon and
TripAdvisor to see that.
But one tool that I really want
to show is WebPageTest,
and I'm going to show it with
a site called RetailMeNot.
This page I just loaded now.
I'm going to do a shift refresh
because it's so fast.
The developers behind this have
worked quite a bit on the
page load time, and
it really shows.
But what's really cool is
taking a look at what
WebPageTest tells us.
So I ran this just
earlier today.
So this is RetailMeNot, assuming
a cable internet
connection inside Chrome.
And so here, if you've seen
WebPageTest before-- it's been
around for a while--
you might know it has the
waterfalls and stuff.
It has a lot more than that.
I really encourage you
to take another look.
First thing I'm going to show
is the filmstrip view.
So over here in the filmstrip
view, we have--
just like before, every 100
milliseconds, we have a
snapshot of what the
page looks like.
And you can see, at 0.9 seconds,
we start to have an
actual page being rendered.
It's really cool.
As I scroll through this, you
can see my waterfall.
We're going through my network
waterfall, and we're seeing
that correlation.
Now, another really nice thing
is that you can ask
WebPageTest to capture the
DevTools timeline recording.
And so we can just view
the DevTools timeline
associated with this.
So I'm just going to
do that right now.
So Chrome DevTools has a
web app, as you know.
So we're just viewing
this as a web app.
And this is the actual recording
that we are looking
at on the WebPageTest.
And we can see a lot more.
So we can see, here's the data
coming in, the HTML.
Google Analytics causes
a layout.
They're asking for
offset width.
So you get the screen size.
And we come down here.
And pretty soon,
we get a paint.
And so this is that paint,
that 818 milliseconds.
That's why we are seeing
a thumbnail right then.
The last thing I'll show is
that it even takes those
numbers from the timeline and
aggregates them over the load
of the page.
So we can actually see, for that
entire duration that it
was recording, let's summarize
all the time that it spent in
Layout, in JavaScript,
in Paint.
And so we can see here, for that
page load time, where was
the browser spending
it's time?
So here we're mostly spending
a lot of time in JavaScript,
to be honest.
But Layout does contribute
a little bit to this.
So WebPageTest, really
cool, had a
lot of features recently.
And the nice thing is that you
can take the difference
between multiple recordings
and be able to track your
performance over time.
If you use webpagetest.org,
the site you're
testing has to be online.
But you can run a private
instance.
So you can run against
a development
server if you want.
It's all open source.
So to sum up, a few things.
We heard a lot of
numbers tonight.
Under 16 milliseconds
is smooth animation.
Under 100 milliseconds feels
pretty much instant.
Under one second, mm,
I'm OK with it.
Over a millisecond,
users are unhappy.
So here are some aggressive
but good goals.
And things that we should really
be striving towards.
When it comes to mobile
connectivity, it is hard to
deliver things fast.
But users get really impatient
quite fast.
Shoot to show the content that's
above the folds in
under a second.
One important part of this is
serving the above-the-fold
content in the first 14
kilobytes of response.
This includes the CSS that you
need to render everything
that's above the fold.
You can defer the rest
of the CSS later on.
You don't need it just yet.
But fit in that first
14 kilobytes.
That number is not
totally magic.
It's based off of how TCP
slow-start works.
It's the first time that you're
really going to get a
considerable amount
of data back.
A maximum of 200 millisecond
server response time, 60 FPS
on scrolling, 60 FPS
on transitions.
And a speed index of under 1,000
would be pretty good.
So aside from reaching those
goals, which are hefty but
good, what can you do?
It seems, talking to the people
that I do, a lot of
people explain that it's hard
to make the case to work on
performance.
You know, you've got
to ship features.
You've got to get that
out the door.
People expect the end results.
And I think we really need to be
able to make the case that
performance is incredibly
important.
And the best way to do that
is, you can show them the
numbers from Google, and Amazon,
and Microsoft, and
anyone who has said that it
affects the bottom line
significantly.
But I think most people really
want to see it with their own
site, with their own data.
So find, in your own analytics,
ways to correlate
performance wins to actual
business wins
that they care about.
So maybe, the speed index
correlated to conversion rate.
People that are experiencing
your site faster are
performing better.
Make the case to your client
that performance often might
trump their feature request.
That awesome, cool feature that
the user will find once
they register for your site,
they probably won't get to
that if they're waiting 10
seconds for the site to load.
Set up infrastructure
to track your perf.
So you can identify, over the
development of the project,
how if you're addressing
performance or if it's improving.
And to be honest, there's
some tools available.
I showed some of them tonight.
But I think it's still quite
early in the space.
And the open-source community
could use a lot more to help
everyone track this
stuff better.
So I encourage you to join a
project or start a new project
to help everyone in this area.
All right.
Thanks, everyone.
Stick around.
We're going to do Q&A
in a little bit.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: Thank
you, Paul.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
PETER LUBBERS: We have
a great gift for you.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
PETER LUBBERS: I think
you will enjoy.
PAUL IRISH: Thanks, Vanessa.
Thank you very much.
Wow!
PETER LUBBERS: All right.
So we need a couple minutes
to set up the Q&A panel.
You can get up for
a little bit.
We'll probably call back in
about seven minutes or so, and
then have everyone back
up here for the Q&A.
At about 9:30, 9:35, we'll
start with the raffle.
There's still some
wine in the back.
I think the beer
is almost gone.
And we'll just reset.
And we'll be right back.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETER LUBBERS: All right.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Let's make our way
up to the front.
We're going to get started
for the Q&A session.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETER LUBBERS: All right,
so, Q&A time.
And if those of you in
the back that are not
participating, maybe just go a
little bit in a quieter area
in the very back.
Right, that's a problem.
Hey, everybody!
Can we get the noise down in
the back a little bit, so
everyone can--
yeah, thank you.
So who's got a question?
I have a mic for you
coming your way.
We're going to pass
this mic around.
We'll repeat the question here
from the expert panel.
PAUL LEWIS: Take it, Jake.
Take it.
COLT MCANLIS: I vote Jake.
PAUL LEWIS: Jake, take it!
JAKE ARCHIBALD: The word
"expert" feels wrong.
COLT MCANLIS: Expert.
AUDIENCE: Can you hear me?
PANEL: Yep.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Actually, my question
was for Jake, the--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh.
AUDIENCE: --last one.
So first thing is, really, every
time I use Chrome Dev
Tools, they seem
to [INAUDIBLE].
It's really great.
But I still have one concern
about the whole thing.
That's I get concerned about the
fact you say in the talk
that if it's slow, use translate
z, and put zero
[INAUDIBLE].
And, actually, I have the
impression it's like you are
expecting people to understand
the [INAUDIBLE]
by doing that.
And I'm pretty sure most people
will just not get it.
And it can actually harm
other browsers.
Or it can harm even Chrome,
because you do something wrong
in [INAUDIBLE].
I don't know, would it?
And it's kind of like saying
to people, you're good.
Go just to assemble.
And so people who are really
good at assembling will make
the cut very fast.
And it's amazing!
And we'd say, oh, I
mean, assemble.
Oh, I know, my god, it's
10 times faster.
And someone else will try and
will just make a mess.
And it will be much slower
because he tried to optimize.
And I think a compiler might
do a better job.
So all you're trying to--
PAUL LEWIS: So the question--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
repeat the question.
PAUL LEWIS: So the question
is why are you saying use
something like translate z when
for something that could
be an anti-pattern or it
could just be misused?
Fair question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Cool.
All right, so firstly,
what we always say is
profile your stuff.
Learn to use profilers.
OK, if you start just applying
rules that you've heard
secondhand, it will work
some of the time.
It may not work in others.
And it may just be a
complete disaster.
So firstly, learn to profile.
What I've been saying recently
is that when you write code,
you should expect it to work
according to the spec.
But as Jake pointed out,
loads of stuff
isn't actually specced.
And so to get great performance,
sometimes you
have to understand the
implementation of the
specification.
It's a reality of what we do.
And that's OK.
Yeah, we should just
accept that.
We're growing up
as an industry.
We're doing more, and
we're going to have
to understand more.
It's a slightly uncomfortable
thing.
There are always people who will
just apply stuff and make
a mess of it.
And we'd much rather they'd
learn to profile and figure
that stuff out.
But right now, this is the way
to get past the problem.
We'd rather you didn't
have the problem.
We're always working to try and
find better ways of doing
Chrome so that we don't
have these problems.
But it's a case of saying,
look, if you need to work
around this problem, here
is a way to do it.
We're looking at ways from
our side as well
to make that happen.
So is that fair?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Although I
think there is a lot of
validity in what you're saying,
like the advice that
we could give today might
not work tomorrow.
I mean, an example of this
would be, we used to give
advice like, if you are going to
concatenate a string, don't
use plus, right?
That'd be insane.
No, use an array, and then join
the array at the end.
And that was faster at the time,
but now it's slower than
just doing a normal string
concatenation.
But, yeah, so these are tips
that today will make your ship
really fast.
But you need to be
on top of that.
You need to be checking
it tomorrow.
Look after your site if a new
browser comes along that does
something different.
And mobile especially can't
handle a lot of layers.
Then, yeah, profile it, and
if it's not helping,
do something different.
PETER LUBBERS: Question
over here.
AUDIENCE: So I'm trying to
use my time offline.
To me it seems like you're in a
really good memory problem,
basically, where you store all
of your assets locally.
And then they only update
afterwards.
So it compares a lot.
And I wanted to hear that.
Except that the user never
has to update anything.
They just use the app and all
in the background later.
And despite the fact that they
don't always have the absolute
latest version of the site,
basically starting with a
fresh project, what would be
your recommendation, to use
HTML5 offline or not?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK, so,
repeat the question.
Would you recommend using HTML5
offline on a new project?
If by HTML5 offline, we mean
application cache--
uuh, eeeh, aaah, eeeh-- if it's
a single page app, then
you could probably
get away with it.
But if you have URLs, which the
web should, then you're
probably going to get a lot
of pain trying to do that.
But we're working on
a new thing, right?
We've got this navigation
controller where you--
PAUL LEWIS: Service Worker.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Service
Worker!
Well, we'll change
the name again.
Don't worry about it.
Don't try to remember
anything.
Yeah, yeah.
Thanks.
But the idea is that you're
going to have this web worker
that is going to be able
to receive events.
And one of those events is going
to be fetch, when the
browser tries to go
away and fetch
something from the network.
And you can cancel that event in
the same way you can cancel
a click on a link.
And you could do something
else, which could mean it
might pull something from a
cache or make up a response
and serve it.
And you're right.
The native apps, they serve
something from the cache
straight away and then go
and look for an update.
And that's the model that
we're promoting.
I've been banging on
about progressive
enhancement for a while.
But this is a next
step of that.
We're going to treat the network
as an enhancement that
might not be present.
So yeah, that's what you'd do,
have a native app model, serve
stuff that's there, and then
make an extra request for
updated data.
And let that fail silently, and
that will be your offline
experience.
PETER LUBBERS: OK, we've got a
question right over there.
AUDIENCE: I'm a little new.
So not that I didn't love the
analogy with the pirates, but
can you do a brief
summary and--
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Excellent,
sir.
AUDIENCE: Well, we could the
garbage collection and--
COLT MCANLIS: Gaarrr-bage
collection.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah,
absolutely.
So it all comes down to this.
Is that garbage collection
events only kick off when
there's unreferenced objects
sitting around
in your memory heap.
So you allocate an object, you
de-reference it, and it's
sitting around.
This is going to happen
over time.
You're just going to continue
to do this.
At some time, you won't
be able to control it.
It'll happen randomly.
The garbage collector will
decide it's time to take 10
milliseconds of your frame.
It'll stop.
I'll do some work.
It'll clear out your
unreferenced objects.
And then, it will give
control back to you.
This will eat your frame rate.
Now, it won't eat the
frame rate equally
across every apps.
I think what we were trying to
say earlier was tools not
rules, right?
Which means take everything we
say up here with a grain of
salt against whatever
you're profiling.
So the whole point of my talk
was don't let your objects
die, and it'll keep your GC from
actually running, which
means you actually have to
manage the memory yourself.
This is something I've been
harping on JavaScript
developers for almost a year now
is, quit being JavaScript
developers.
Start looking back towards the
trends you see in C and C++,
because those patterns of
writing code actually result
in very, very fast JavaScript
execution.
So sorry for everyone in here
who doesn't agree with that.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: You've got
the microphone now.
AUDIENCE: OK, so we have a lot
of really good profiling tools
in a desktop environment--
PANEL: Oh, yeah, he's going
to ask about mobile.
AUDIENCE: --if we're profiling
in a mobile environment,
that's real, not emulated.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, so everything
that we showed
today in the Chrome Developer
Tools works against Chrome and
Android, all of it.
COLT MCANLIS: Give us
a round of applause.
PAUL LEWIS: Yay!
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL IRISH: So the memory
management stuff, I didn't
show the frame rate meter.
But actually the frame rate
meter also shows you your
available GPU memory and how
much is currently being
consumed, which gets really
interesting when you are
scrolling images into view and
out of view, and images are
being decoded into
memory and not.
And so, Chrome in Android
has extremely
extensive developer tools.
Firefox does as well.
And mobile Safari does
now as well.
So really the only browser
that does not have good
tooling is the legacy Android
browser in the web view.
But as far as dealing with that,
your options are that
you have [? Winery. ?]
And you don't have a lot of
the performance tooling.
But pretty much you can
extrapolate the performance of
Android browser based on the
performance tools that you use
inside Chrome.
So debugging Chrome in Android,
all the improvements
that you make will have huge
impacts in Android browser.
PAUL LEWIS: One thing that I
think it does touch on is you
still need the device.
And this remains a challenge
that you can't emulate the GPU
of a mobile device from
a desktop device.
It's just not the same thing.
It's not got the same driver.
That remains a challenge.
I don't think there's a good
answer yet other than have the
device that you're trying to
ship for on your desk tested
against that profile in that.
You may have a lot of
devices ultimately.
But there isn't a shortcut
to that process.
I mean, you can get really far
just using Chrome DevTools
against a decent Nexus
device, for example.
You can do that.
And you can get pretty far.
And you can extrapolate,
as Paul said.
But you might need to just
get specific devices.
COLT MCANLIS: It is worth
pointing out there's a
fantastic blog post out there
that shows with the Nexus 10
device you can actually emulate
different frequencies
and patterns.
And you're actually able to
emulate a whole swath of
different performance profiles
with a single item, including
different resolutions
and whatnot.
So find that post on G+.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm just going to
throw in that I have seen bugs
very specifically on certain
handsets for the GPU that
didn't manifest themselves on
anything other than very
specific hardware.
So sometimes you're just going
to have to buy it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I haven't said
anything for this question.
And I'm feeling left out.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So--
COLT MCANLIS: Give it back!
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: We've got our
next question, right here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so thanks for
some great performance tips.
I think this goes
for Paul Lewis.
I think you showed some examples
of that I, as a
developer, as a front-end guy, I
need to combine an animation
frame, and a scroll handler,
and an [? event ?] handler.
And I need to combine
some positions.
I need to remove some class.
If I'm scrolling into a group
performance, I think that's a
lot of complexity to add on
each individual front-end
developer in this room,
that I need to figure
out, OK, I'm scrolling.
So I should probably remove
a class so I don't have
concessions.
And--
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
AUDIENCE: --do you think
that's a problem?
Or we you looking into some
ways that we can annotate
these things, including
the different ways?
PAUL IRISH: That's
a good question.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, the tools
should tell you, I think.
The question is, OK, dealing
with this performance of
scrolling, getting fast
scrolling adds a lot of
complexity for developers.
Is that a good thing?
A bad thing?
Evil?
Happy?
Smile, smile--
no, as I said, first of all,
again, it's a tools thing.
If you don't have this problem,
don't worry about it.
If you do have a bottleneck,
you want to solve it.
If you play the cards right, you
should expect the browser
to do the right thing.
You shouldn't expect
fast performance.
You have to understand the
implementation today.
That gap will close
over time as the
implementation gets better.
But it doesn't remove a
developer's responsibility to
understand the system they're
programming for.
COLT MCANLIS: [CLAPPING].
PAUL LEWIS: [LAUGHS].
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Thank you.
Well said.
PAUL LEWIS: I try.
Where that line is--
I think the thing that
personally frustrates me is
how easy it is for you to shoot
yourself in the foot today.
I would love for it to be
impossible for you to shoot
yourself in the foot.
I would.
But I don't think that's going
to happen anytime soon.
We're doing everything we
can to make sure that
your code runs well.
And you can imagine--
the web is the most general
computing case that you can
probably think of.
Every developer writes code
differently, that has
different problems in different
places, because you
can do pretty much whatever
you feel like doing.
This is great.
This is the brilliance
of the web.
It's unbounded.
But writing something that can
interpret unbounded and do it
well without you having to
step in and go, actually,
here's what I meant,
Mr. Browser.
AUDIENCE: That's why my second
part of the question was, are
we looking into other ways we
can annotate this so, hey, my
elements I've got animation
from the
scrolling key card has--
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --rendering
some little--
PAUL LEWIS: Right, so we've
just recently added a Show
Potential Scroll Bottlenecks
checkbox inside DevTools,
which is like it's going to put
a box around it and go,
hey, you have a touch handler
here, which, for various
reasons, will get in the way.
A mouse wheel handler
is very similar.
So we're looking at ways, where
we see these things crop
up, that we flag them to you,
give you the kind of alert
that this might be a thing.
And it's kind of a hand-in-hand
thing.
Hopefully, you'll then
go, huh, I maybe
don't need that there.
I'll remove it.
COLT MCANLIS: Can
I say something
angsty, really quick.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: I want
to make sure we get
through all the questions.
But I want to say something
super angsty.
Because I'm the angry
bald one.
He's the happy bald one.
Let's be very clear.
This is a perfmatters meet-up.
This is a perfmatters talk.
You're here because you care
about performance.
You're here because you should
own performance, right?
The browser will do what the
browser's going to do.
The spec is going to do what
the spec is going to do.
You are in charge of
your performance.
Ye be the master of
ye ship, right?
AUDIENCE: Aarrr!
COLT MCANLIS: And the browsers
are going to optimize
differently.
But, dear god, if anyone in
this perfmatters meet-up
thinks that any other view
besides you are responsible
for your performance is the
right one, I'm sorry, but
you're missing the boat here,
literally, right?
Own your performance.
Take pride in it.
Perf matters.
Wear it like a badge.
Show it to your boss, your wife,
your ex-girlfriend who
thinks you're not worth
anything anymore.
Wear the badge.
Make it your credence.
And you will ship
better products.
Don't wait for the platform.
Don't wait for the browser.
Don't wait for the guy
sitting next to you.
Be the captain of
your damn ship.
Thank you.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm going to add
something boring to that,
in that part of the standards
process is we--
because if you're finding that
you're doing these tricks with
JavaScript to enhance
performance, like adding an
element over the top to catch
hover events so you see
they're not going down to the
CSS, make noises about that on
the standards groups as well.
Because when we see this common
pattern happening loads
of times, we can put that
directly in CSS, and it will
be faster still.
We saw this with things like
query selector role, CSS
animations, that
kind of thing.
PAUL LEWIS: Actually, generally,
just let us know if
you find something that
really sucks from a
performance point of view.
We love those because we put
those in front of engineers.
We talk it through with them.
We either would say, oh, yeah.
You could change a code.
And that would fix
this problem.
Or it's just something that's
like a platform thing that
we're trying to fix
and fix quickly.
So if you find anything that's
just pathologically bad, then
just let us know.
We'd love to see a bug
filed against it.
And then we've got something
to rally around.
OK, all right.
AUDIENCE: --That kind of sums up
what you just talked about.
The HTML5 Dev Conference
introduces things like, hey,
spice up your pages with
CSS animations.
So I actually had a situation
where I wanted one button to
stand out as a command people
should be noticing.
And I put it in.
And all of a sudden, a couple
weeks later, I realize that my
CPU's getting eaten up.
And so, I think, to put it in
Colt's terms, we've been given
a plank, and we can walk
off it, if we wish, OK?
And so, I totally agree.
This was very enlightening
today.
And so, I had an offline
discussion
with a couple of you.
And I'm very impressed
with the tools.
And I think one of the next
steps potentially to take--
and I'd like your commentary on
it-- is a little bit of AI
to say, hey, how are you
shooting yourself in the foot?
How are you killing yourself?
Because a lot of people are very
functionally oriented and
aren't really proactively
looking at the tools.
So I'd just like your
comments on that.
PAUL IRISH: One of the things
that we want to do inside the
Chrome DevTools is--
right now, the situation is
that if your interested in
performance, you profile.
You look at the results.
You interpret them, and
you make changes.
And that works extremely well.
But it doesn't reach everyone.
Because not everyone asks the
question, why am I slow?
Why is this not great?
So one of the things that we
want to explore is being a bit
more proactive in our
recommendations.
So oh, I noticed that you're
not concatenating your
JavaScript and production.
And I noticed that you
have paint storms.
I noticed that you're layout
thrashing for three seconds as
you're loading the page.
And we have abilities to
determine this and show that
to the user.
We're not there yet.
But it's something that we
definitely want to do.
PETER LUBBERS: We got
two more questions.
And if we could keep
them pretty short.
AUDIENCE: Sure, really
quickly.
Using the WebPageTest
thing, I think it's
a performance thing.
Stuff that happens after
the [INAUDIBLE]
captures stuff up till there.
Does that matter in terms of
loading more network access
and stuff, after that event?
Do you think that matters to--
PAUL LEWIS: I think we've all
got an opinion on this one,
apart from Colt.
AUDIENCE: --mostly to things
like search engines and such.
I guess it could also
be used as--
PAUL IRISH: I don't think
I understand it.
PAUL LEWIS: No, I don't think
I-- now, you've added the
search engine thing.
PAUL IRISH: Could you repeat?
Because we're not
exactly sure.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Do you mean our
search engine's going to
penalize you for extraloading
after onload?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
Because WebPageTest mostly
does until that point.
PAUL IRISH: Ah, OK.
So on WebPageTest, the
definition of fully rendered
for WebPageTest is 2 seconds of
idle network activity after
window onload.
So it basically looks at the
network waterfall, makes sure
that the network activity
is still and
that the page is done.
And that is how they determine
doneness, which seems like a
reasonable thing.
Search engines are pretty
OK with that, too.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, if it's
a great user experience for
you to get to first render
really quickly, but then use
the network to cache stuff for
the next page or start loading
something further down
the page, do that.
Don't do something else because
you think it's going
to get you a better
rank on Google.
Because ultimately, Google is
going to change how it works,
how it search indexes based on
what gives the best user
experience.
So never try and game it.
PAUL LEWIS: Just sort of
related, every time you do the
progressive enhancement thing,
and you load the page.
And then you run some JavaScript
that injects
something else into the page.
And then you do some Ajax,
and you put something
else into the page.
Just out of interest, remember
that you're paying the tax
every time you do that.
Because you're going
to have to layout--
well, recalc style, "layout."
You're actually
going to parse HTML--
recalc style, layout, paint,
uncomposite for each one of
those things just in the
process of loading.
So there's a real balancing
act here.
It's not a one-size-fits-all,
right?
You want to get stuff
on screen quickly.
But if you keep nudging things
along, you're going to pay
that tax several times over.
So just profile it, figure
out what your
metrics are for winning--
yay--
and then go there.
MALE SPEAKER:Are we
on last question?
AUDIENCE: Hey, Colt--
PETER LUBBERS: OK, I
guess we'll have
two final quick questions.
COLT MCANLIS: Yes.
PETER LUBBERS: Quick answers.
COLT MCANLIS: Sweet.
I'll answer in 10 words.
AUDIENCE: So isn't your object
pool going to have to be
pretty specialized to not
proffer any classes?
And also isn't GC time
proportional to number of live
objects, especially
in mark and sweep?
So will your mark and sweep be
super, super long, if you
happen to incur one.
COLT MCANLIS: Yes, you should
have object pools that are
unique to class-specific data.
I generally disagree that you
should write JavaScript with
heterogeneous types in it.
You should have an object and
duplicates of that that are
heterogeneous.
Again, that's my
C++ background.
And yes, mark and sweep
is fantastic.
And the iterational garbage
collector in V8 is probably
one of the most cutting
edge you'll find
anywhere in the industry.
However, you still lose time.
And we can sit here and debate
all day about the
micro-optimizations.
Go to the tools.
PETER LUBBERS: And our final
question of the night.
AUDIENCE: Right, these questions
are for the angry
pirate captain.
So you talk about reallocating
your memory, and that's the
memory that you can
control, like all
your JavaScript objects.
What about the stuff you can't
control, like images floating
in and out of view?
I know in something I'm working
on in the moment, I
have very little JavaScript
getting allocated.
But it just ramps
up and GC pops.
And it's because a lot of
images are floating
in and out of view.
Can you control the garbage
collection on
that stuff as well?
COLT MCANLIS: That's a
fantastic question.
For people who didn't hear that
on the live stream, can
you control the garbage
collection of things that
aren't JavaScript-created
objects, images, DOM, and
stuff like that?
So we could sit down and profile
your whole site and
give you a million different
ways to handle this.
The short answer is,
yes, if you're
willing to be super tricky.
For instance, objects will come
down off the network and
images will be created.
You can't fix that.
That's under the hood.
But how it's resident in your
memory on the page, for
example, having a static pool
of 10 canvases, right?
And then, swapping and managing
in how those canvases
are filled as sprite sheets and
how the UV coordinates on
that is handled could definitely
be a potential
solution for that that would
cut down a lot of your
texture-memory residency
there.
So thousands of different
things, depending on all of
your use cases.
Again, this comes back to it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You can
talk about that.
PAUL LEWIS: I think, in general,
something like the
image one, very specifically,
we're working really hard.
There are loads of optimizations
we feel that we
can make in terms of image
decoding and image resizing in
the pipeline.
When you see them crop up in
DevTools and you see these
huge green spikes of paint, and
you see a little arrow.
And you're like, I know
what's inside this.
You spin it and it goes,
image decode.
Image resize!
And you're like, yeah, I
knew that was coming.
And we want that to be a
complete nonissue, right?
We just want it to go away.
We have ideas.
The engineers are
looking at it.
It's a thing.
So we want it to go away.
In the short term, it's
about avoiding resize,
like we said before.
It's about doing all you
can to mitigate it.
But it's just one of these
things that is hopefully going
to get better over time.
We know it's a thing.
We want it to be better.
But can go crazy and do
the canvas thing.
I did that.
It's weird.
COLT MCANLIS: But it works.
PAUL LEWIS: It works.
But you just go so
far off road.
You understand that the
browser does it
for you for a reason.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Can
I say something?
PAUL LEWIS: No, Peter's
going to take it away.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No--
COLT MCANLIS: Don't
give it to him!
Don't give it to him!
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Aaah!
[LAUGHS]
The guy who did really well
on the quiz that I
did, I owe you swag.
Yeah, come up to the front.
And you'll get swag.
Brilliant.
In a minute.
COLT MCANLIS: Not now.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'll
stay here.
COLT MCANLIS: That'd
be super awkward.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: If you just came
up here, and we're like, yay!
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'll
present to you.
PETER LUBBERS: All right,
well, one more time.
A big round of applause for
these great speakers.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LUBBERS: Thank you.
Everybody on the live stream, we
had over 200 people on the
live streaming, which
was great.
Everybody, thanks for joining.
And that was one of the longest
average view time,
like 25 minutes per person.
So that was awesome.
So thanks for joining us.
All of these talks
were recorded.
But they will be posted on our
site shortly on the Google
Developers Live site as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Tell
your friends.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
And we'd like your feedback.
So if there is on the
meet-up site--
when you're done, you're
probably going to get an email
seeing if you can
give a rating.
Let us know your feedback.
We're always open to making
changes for the better.
So I hope you enjoyed it.
And we're going to say goodbye
to the live stream and move on
to the raffle here.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]